Ladies and gentlemen,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on
the link that says fleshlight and during
the code name Brogan, you get 15%
off. All right, and would that said,
toggle up bitches,
the Joe Rogan experience.
[inaudible]
Brian thinks it's funny to keep
playing that black guy's voice.
They totally forgot it. Fake
Black Guy's voice. It's much more,
much more offensive. Um,
before we get started,
I think I have to say
more about the flashlight.
Don't think that's a 15 second ad.
Awesome. I shoot loads into
it. I recommend you do the
same. Can I help in on this?
Yes. Kevin Pereira wants to shoot loads
into a flashlight. We're going to,
I want to believe in a world
where I can, but as I said, I,
I get a wave of guilt and sin and filth
that washes over me every time I climax.
And I can't imagine saving that into a,
a fleshy device that it didn't have
to dishwasher. It feels better,
but it's more embarrassing. Yeah. And
Kevin's brought wine, but I'll do it.
Gentleman were sophisticates here.
Here's me mate. Cheers. This is,
I mean we have wine. Coconut water. Yeah,
we got coffee and were stoned and
you know, I don't, um, there's a,
there's a thing I have, I don't have
a lot of obsessive compulsive shit,
but one thing I have is if you make
an a toast, you got to click glasses.
Whatever buddy. Yes. Yeah. What is this
like sort of half ass gesture. It's,
some people don't want to lean across
the table. Listen, you lazy bitch. Okay.
Are we all in this together?
What?
We've got clink glasses and you
have to tap it on the ground on,
on the table first before you drink it. Oh
really? Yeah. You do. What's that about?
I, I know tag back thing. You just
have to do it. I've never done that.
Does that signify I'm done my glasses
in my whole life. I've done them wrong.
You've been sending
mixed messages to people.
You could be getting in
fights and not know it.
This is like a Jujitsu technique where
you realize you couldn't finish it.
What all you had to do was just one
little thing. One little thing different.
I didn't click like, goddammit
gentleman, here's the mulligans chairs.
Mulligans I don't even know what that
means. What does a gap is a do over, over.
I never played golf. Got Tap Joe.
You've just didn't tap. Yeah. Yeah.
I never, I never, he
tap, tap and pitch it.
Shut myself.
Out of all the Douchey tee shirts I've
ever seen related to mixed martial arts,
one of them was tap or
snap. Oh, so up to you.
And then may fashion has got to evolve,
man.
How many wolves and skeletons and
chains can you wear around your neck?
Ag Your Four. You're asking to get
in a fight. I got this new company.
It's about the brick off called break
my dick off and your ass fight gear.
This is, this is the
Vulcan. The logo's a dragon.
Fucking a pit bull in the
ass. Covered in glitter, bro.
I need to get you and Dana
white in on this. You know,
you got to do it then new tank top I
two knuckles deep. Oh, it's so cool.
The moment you go two knuckles
deep, man, you're going to tap.
It's a new technique or the guys have to,
yeah,
CPR has been training really mad. I did
not know that he can get three knuckles.
Wow, that's incredible. But then again,
belladonnas only a hundred pounds.
She can get a baseball bat.
That is true. God bless her.
What the fuck is that all about?
That should be an Olympic sport gaping.
It should absolutely be a sport
spitting in the gaping hole,
like a basketball type thing for
accuracy. Right. It's hard to do,
especially when you have a chest
cold cause it sticks to everything.
None of this existed when I was a child.
Now it did just,
I don't think people knew about it.
Do you think you did,
do you think there's a lot of assholes
judging, spitting and assholes?
If we had flip cams back in the 18
hundreds you'd see Victoria and gaping
Victorian era. Some of it,
it's so bad like that, that
God, that Max Hardcore Guy,
that guts,
he went to jail for it.
I mean you got to do something really
fucking creepy for them to be wanting to
lock you up in jail in 2011 or 10 weather.
Well maybe it was even nine for porn.
Yeah, but this fucking guy, man,
he was opening girl's ass holes
up and in the like with like,
like speculums is that what it's called?
Whatever it medical instrument,
a little thing that you stretch it,
a vice grip then peeing in there and then
making girls drinking out with a straw
alleged the leaky basement.
They were talking about this.
A sal was talking about this on the stern
show. Um, I don't know if it's true,
but if it is true, I don't doubt it.
I've seen a lot of shit. Let's see.
I was seeing shit back in the bulletin
board dial up days when I was like nine,
10 years old, which explains a lot. I've
been to sensitize the Russian soldier,
putting his foot on a head and
cutting a neck open and going, oh,
it would be steamy because
it was cold outside.
Like that analysis of fucked up shit at
the age of nine or 10 so I believe it
was all out there.
But what I don't get are how girls are
making money off of non porn because guys
are sexually objectified by it.
Like the the crushers that will crush a
cell phone with a, with a heel or a pump,
a gas pedal on a car. There's a lot of
fucked up. There's don't they can get,
I mean we've,
we do it,
what the fuck segment on our
show where it's like girls that,
that that getting pools wearing Jean
jackets and they make like $30 a month off
subscriptions subscriptions. Cause
some dude's like, oh look at that.
Then I'm getting wet. Oh Mommy spanked
me. Whoa. Now I gotta clean my flashlight.
I lived the minion. Have you ever
seen the menu and it's like a website,
we've talked about this
before where this crazy ugly,
nasty fat guy just fucks these
hot porn stars. But no once,
I mean I could see where it's
like kind of cool that of others.
One Who wants to subscribe to that guy.
That was always the charm of Ron, Jeremy.
Right, right. I kind of beginning
it was a girl beginning.
It was sort of a normal looking guy
but then it became hideous. Took time.
But clearly he's in the hideous realm.
I mean everyone goes bad eventually.
He's fucking hideous and, and
that's, that's part of the charm.
There's something about the Internet
man and technology in general though his
accelerated porn to just an accelerated
depravity and and and just decadence and
to just like really fucking intense
levels that have never existed before.
I mean at first it was seen as this
bastion of hope that was going to elevate
discussion and bring intellectuals
together and further everything. And it,
it has done that to an extent,
but it's really just created
hardcore porn like really hard.
I think the thing is I think it's going
to change young people for good or bad
and probably both.
But I think once you're old
and you already have like
a pattern set in your head,
it's way easier to just jerk off to have
more and more fucked up shit than it is
to like look at the latest findings
on, you know, hyper Novas or you know,
look deep into the, the real possibilities
created by the large Hadron collider.
Like that's too much, man. Fuck that
pink cloud. That's where I'm going.
Exactly what I want to watch some guys
shit and some chick's mouth because I
can't, you know, I mean there's guys
that like, they're so angry at women,
they want to shit in their mouth
like a good, she fucking like,
could she have done just like
just exist and be unattainable.
That's what it is, mom.
And she's right to dude.
So there's a lot of weak bitches
out there. That's what it is.
There's a lot of dudes,
mom issues or not.
You've got to fucking look at the whole
world around you make an assessment,
look what goes on your instincts,
what is positive, what is negative,
what does admirable, what
makes you jealous? Go towards
that. And I always say,
I aspire to be the man that you pretend
to be when you're trying to get laid.
Okay. Aspire to be that guy for real.
Actually become that guy. You know,
just you don't have to use your
mom issues and all that stuff.
Get your shit together bitch.
So that's why I got an m three cause I
want to be the guy that doesn't need a
personality is what I'm talking about.
I want to be the guy or you moist yet.
Plus they're the shit and they're,
they handle awesome. Such good cars.
I love cars, man. I'm a, I'm a,
I'm so fascinated by the engineering that
I couldn't possibly be responsible for
myself. I look at something like a
co m three or something like that.
I think about all the fucking shit that's
involved, all the different settings,
the m setting and all a sudden that
suspension changes. You feel it,
the macro for your car and all of a
sudden it's like the car is, it's sucking.
You buy the asshole and just holding
you back. Just to the engineering.
I believe that there's 30 German
engineers that shed a single tear.
Whenever I put the top down,
like I believe they're so proud of their
work and the time and all the effort
that went into making a
piece of plastic fold.
I believe that they're crying about
us. That's not plastic. The Tufts,
one of the coolest things about the top
of the empty and three convertible m
three converted. We're on it
because it's all one piece. And Mel,
that's like the coolest thing.
And they figured out how to
do recently I could transform.
It goes into like three little sections.
You have two sections in the window.
It's dope. Watch. When he does
it, it's, it's amazing. Like,
it's like an orchestration
of, of, you know,
mechanical engineering break easily isn't
there? Like, you know, like, oh you,
you know, no more shit. You know, the more
moving parts. Yeah. But that's, that's,
that's my life. That's
everybody's life now, right?
We get more shit so that it can break so
that we can get pissed that it's shit.
And it's amazing how reliable
those things are. You know,
they're the most unreliable car ever had
was a Porsche. I had a nine 11 turbo.
They're broke down five times.
It was ridiculous. But BMWs,
I've never had a problem. Japanese
cars, I've never had a problem.
It's amazing how many miles you
can put on a car these days.
And there's no problem.
Like back when you had like a 1970
barracuda or something like that, Yo,
hundred thousand miles,
the things done. All right,
you get your bearings blown and
fucking transmission's gone.
Missing gears and the engine
smells like shit. I mean,
you have to rebuild everything.
Those things just didn't last.
Remember the super as we had with the legs
that popped up, one of years break? No,
I didn't have to always be there.
I had the one with the fixed,
I had a 92 or 93 Toyota supra.
Oh,
when they went to that space shape,
that was the first really cool car that
I got. That was my news radio money.
But uh,
it's just something about just the
engineering of these fucking cars that's
accelerated as well. Like
the empathy, like the m,
this m three that I
have is 420 horsepower.
Well the nine 11 terrible that I had was
like somewhere around the same like 420
horsepower, but it was all turbo charged
and it was like Algebra down. Yeah.
And it's a different sort of a feeling.
Well this car is that with a full v
eight with an 84,000 Rpm, you know,
rev limit.
I mean it's fucking incredible.
Is it 84,000 or 84008000400
but when it hits 8,400 men,
that whale,
it's like a formula one race car.
It sounds obvious in launch control yet.
No,
that sounds like it's going
to kill the transmission. Nah.
Well if you warm your engine up,
you have to drive for x amount of
miles at certain speeds and whatnot.
You can drop it into first
shut off traction control. Uh,
and if you hold the one of the shifter
paddles in or you put it in neutral slam
on the gas while holding
a shifter paddles,
like the checkered flag will
appear on the dash and controls.
There's total Easter eggs in the software.
And then you can use
like your cruise control,
actual controls to boost up the RPM.
So when you let go,
it engages that clutch when you're already
at seven thousand eight thousand rpm
screams and you'll break your neck.
That's bad ass.
What you find out about that Internet.
So it's pretty, it's pretty common. It's,
it's,
it's coming back.
The Nissan's actually did it for
their GTR and when people used it,
it violated the warranty. They say
they say BMW, if you do it over twice,
apparently accounts, how many times you
do it, it violates your warranty too. Wow,
that's funny. That's
ridiculous. Make a better thing.
Don't give me something that breaks
stupid. But the uh, let me, someone was,
could particularly ridiculous
cause it's a God damn race car.
I mean what Nissan was bragging
about what they're Zeros,
the zero to 60 time was ridiculously
low. And the handling. The car's insane.
It's a fucking amazing car. I drove it,
but there's something about it. It's like,
yeah, it's really fast
and yeah, but it's ugly.
It's like it's goofy
looking and it's like,
it's got some sort of a techno Godzilla
thing going on that I'm not really into
it. So like it stands out too much. But
for all the, like if a Ferrari stands out,
you know it stands out but it stands out.
It's like it's beautiful.
That car stands out like what's going on?
Car stand out.
Cause he looked like babies, sneakers on
wheels. It's not a good standard. Yeah,
it's an odd stand out. Like I don't
particularly, I tried to like it.
I like looked around it and stare at it.
I tried to like it but it's,
the engineering though is stunning.
What about electric cars?
Like the Tesla and all that?
They're not ready. You know,
I'm interested in them eventually,
but I'm not interested in something that
you have to charge for 18 hours after
you drive 250 that's, that's stupid.
The Mississippi in the gallons though.
I get 15 gallons of gas
it per the big truck.
I know that shit. Aye. Aye.
Aye. Yeah, it's disgusting.
Well it makes you mad when it starts
hitting four 30 and four I mean what does
it now for 20 for regular in the premiums,
like five thing for 50 at Chevron.
But my point was about the BMW is that
what's really shocking is how much better
engineered they are just over a few
years ago. Like compared to my supra,
like the super was a
really good handling car.
It was like it was but this m it's like
glued to the fucking ground. I love it.
It's just like it's on track first
nice car that I've ever had in my life.
Then it's like you turn the wheel
and the car just goes. Yeah,
it doesn't ask questions.
It's so connected to the road like it's
so it's so like, um, what's the word?
I mean precise, you know like
the way it handles and moves.
The Germans are known for their
precision and shit in the mouth videos.
Then I'll fill out of that too.
What's up with that?
Why are the Germans into those a
scat videos, Germans and Japanese,
you can't point fingers now with the
Internet. Everybody's into everything.
They're just willing to go. It wasn't at
the root. I mean behind every stereotype.
They just had an awesome word for
it. Is that what it shy? Shy Porn.
Wow. I'd like to yell that I sure as
Shit. That's what it is. Shidler his shit.
I had a good word.
I don't know if schizoid itself is or if
that's just an exclamation of make when
you're actually crapping
on someone, but wow. Yeah.
Enough that they had to
fucking label it so often.
Like there's one porn when it got
shit in his mouth. Oh, no, no, no, no.
We have a whole category of that.
What a guy shits on someone's
mouth and there's a category.
That's why people are in tune.
But where else do you put it on the shelf?
At the adult video store, you know?
Yeah. There is no more of those.
They still exist. Do they
exist? I went to, I went to
a sex shop the other day. Uh,
just the Loobren standard run of the mill,
uh,
and feel like we're going
to be hearing music.
Where's this going to Albertsons
thinking were there special you now?
But this guy comes up to the counter and
he buys a card. He's like, he's like,
I'd like a $5 in the booth and,
and like a dude went,
got a plastic card and they had a whole
video adult video arcade back there and
I saw at least 10 different people come
in and the short time that I was there
to buy video cards to go in
the back and beat off. Wow.
Maybe there was something way cooler.
Maybe there was the glory hole action
or maybe it was a unicorn ride.
I don't know what was
happening back there.
Like maybe there was some crazy
shit going on. My friend Johnny,
God rest his soul. He used
to go to New York. He was a,
he's an addict and used to smoke
crack and go to those peep shows.
That was his thing.
When he would smoke crack,
you would want to go hide and go to peep
shows. He shows in those places all day.
Just give the girl money. It would
tell me these horror stories of what?
What kind of women are on the other side,
like showing you their asshole.
Do you think like girls that are like
in the glass boxes like behind like you
know like what's that?
That that that hotel where they have a
girl in the glass box behind the checkout
that's on sunset. Have you ever seen that?
Yes. I know he talking about standard.
Is it the Santander?
Do you think like that?
That that's like the upgraded version of
the peep show girl was like, oh my God.
They'd like,
like they fight with each other back in
the box of the standard this weekend.
It's no people that don't
know what we're talking about.
When you go to the standard,
as you go into the lobby,
the standard hotel in Hollywood
has the desk where the,
they check you in and above the desk.
There's like a fish tank,
like a big fish tank with a woman in it
and she's hot and she's in her underwear
and she's reading a book or she's
checking her email. It's weird. Yeah,
and she's not supposed
to interact with you.
They don't look at you and smile and wave
cause that would be so anti la in la.
No one pays attention to you.
It's not like she's there to greet you
like in Vegas and they're going to hire a
hot chick. They'd hire you. Hello.
Welcome the casino. Nice to meet you.
Do you need help with your bags in la?
She's in her underwear reading their
email and you're like looking at her.
I was with Doug Benson in Vegas and
they had one of those same things,
but the girls like worlds so
excited to see Doug Benson.
They got out of character and got out
of the glass box to take a photo with
awful Doug Benson.
Did that end with Benson in the box,
shaken it for people
who are making out with,
I'd love that.
I'm so jealous and envious of
people that can perform while stone.
Loosen your stone right now. Stop
lying. Allegedly. Stop lying.
Stop lying to America. You know, you said
something in your, in your, your Twitter,
when you were tweeting about coming
here that you were worried about ruining
your career. I thought that
was hilarious. Not worried.
I was excited by the possibility
ruining not my current,
like I could pretty much caught
doing whatever I need to on g four.
I mean the audience gets it, you
know, they're all young dudes too.
But if I am on the precipice of either
homelessness or potentially legitimizing
myself and you know, this is, this
might be a nudge in one direction.
You think so man, I think it's a
nudge towards the right direction.
I have always said that if I can't
say or do something that I want to do,
I'm in the wrong business or I'm
doing the wrong show. Well you can do,
you can back yourself into a corner
and not even realize it's happening.
You know,
you get on a certain show and that
certain show wants a certain standard of
behavior. I mean there's a reason why
Charlie Sheen is bouncing back like this.
He's like a girl that's been molested, you
know, girls been molested, they wait. No,
it's not that he's a victim.
It's like when you do something that
you don't want to do and you have to
pretend to be someone you're not,
there's like,
then when you get pushed in one way
there's inelasticity to life and it makes
you bounce in the other way.
And it's like, you know,
like we were talking to Dana d Armand
and she was talking about our family was
like, you know, hey smoke pot, do
whatever you want but don't drink.
So I fucking drank. You know, there's
a, you push someone in one direction,
you're too controlling and one
direction they rebel, you know,
there's not a great, a great and,
and you know, like I said, if, if,
if I can't say or do like I'd absolutely
lost and an endorsement deals,
I've lost all sorts of stuff from,
I'm not going to say that
I'm not going to do that.
And while it may have cost me short term,
I think long term it's the way to go.
So if we're talking about chais are
porn and BMWs, so be it, cheers,
it just a matter of time before there
is no more sensors and standards and all
that nonsense.
Like the Internet is pretty much kind of
squashed a good huge chunk of that shit.
You know, you agree you can put
your content out fast. Yeah,
I worry about that ending at some
point to me to do, especially as this,
the notion of Ip TV, Internet, TV,
and we'll get to the Google
thing probably at some point.
But that notion that the distribution
method or the way you're getting the
content is going to matter in five years.
It's not.
So when people turn on the TV and
they're watching the internet,
there's to be calls for regulations
and clamp downs just the way there is.
And you'll still be able to self
distribute always that will,
that avenue will be there to an extent.
There's no regulation on cable. Cable is,
it's not regulated by the FCC. Yeah. Yeah.
But then if you don't use advertisers,
I mean isn't that what motivates it?
It's very difficult.
It's going to be very difficult
to rationalize, imposing
some sort of standards.
What, how something really
fucked up happening and
that's what you really have to
worry about it. And this is fucking
tinfoil hat conspiracy theory 101 okay.
It sounds absolutely ridiculous,
but if you were the government and
you realize that, hey look what,
what of all these rebellions all across
the world have in common while they have
in common,
these people organize on the Internet
in a way that was never possible before.
Hmm, okay. How do we stop
that from happening? Well,
we have to figure out a way that the
internet is evil and so then the internet
gets used for something or blamed for
something and there's some sort of a
terrorist attack that was
coordinated by the Internet. Okay.
There is a way around this and
you can still enjoy your internet.
[inaudible] I mean there's,
there's not,
there's been legislation proposed
the Internet kill switch,
which people were talking about like mad
and it was actually right before Egypt
happened. And then it's, they actually
discussed it right as Egypt was happening.
Yeah. That main revolt, that notion
that up. It's for your safety, security.
There's something going on.
This switches now flipped and there goes
your Internet where we have no idea how
much of crises and political
overthrowing of governors,
you know,
fucking warlords and and mayors and we
have no idea how much of this shit is
engineered,
how much of foreign dictators they're,
they're getting overthrown is engineered
and engineered by the CIA general.
Wesley Clark was talking about this.
There's a video that I was watching,
I put it on my Twitter a couple of days
ago, but he was talking in 2007 okay.
In detail about the plans that are
in place to overthrow dictatorships
throughout the world, including
Libya. Gaddafi was, yeah,
they were supporting Gadhafi up until
that bitter end and then they said, okay,
now we're going to on the rentals so that
they could eventually become al Qaeda
and hate us as well.
Once they get into power.
The whole thing is completely ridiculous.
It's our relation to our
reputation squandered. It's God.
Wasn't there a point in time?
I remember being younger and being told
USA number one and believing that, okay,
that's what the world thought.
They all expired. But now,
now we're a bunch of scared old men,
a bunch of scared old men that want
to keep everybody down. I mean,
that's what it seems like. I mean, this,
this whole country seems like a
bunch of meddling fucks, you know?
And when it comes to the rest
of the world, if I didn't know,
if I wasn't American and I
didn't know that, you know,
most of us here are as much victims
as the people around the world.
It's just not happening to us physically.
But we're,
we're just as taken apart by this machine
and pushed into a direction outside of
our control.
It's not like we want this to happen.
The disparity between rich
and poor in this country.
It's far greater than the disparity
of rich and poor and many miss Middle
Eastern place. Wow. Yeah, man, listen,
we can't get started on that again.
I'll go on an inside job. You know rampage
about the, the financial institutions.
It's about fucking into socks.
Let's talk about anything.
We watched a inside job the other day,
Steven, have you seen it? You've seen it.
It's mine. So brutal. Do you, what we've,
what we've done financially is the
same thing we're doing, you know,
with with other parts of the world as
far as like with resources and you know,
invading countries and dominating things.
What we're doing things with no regard
whatsoever to the consequences and no
regard whatsoever for in how we're,
we are viewed and that's the
thing about this inside job.
All these guys didn't have any problem
walking with hundreds of millions of
dollars and looking absolutely
ridiculous looking horrible.
If they can get away with it,
they're going to do it.
And it's exactly the same shit that's
happening thing with America and all these
other worlds and other parts of the world.
What's going on in Iraq would no one
is mentioning the fact that literally a
million people are dead over there.
A fucking million people died in Iraq
and we know for a fact there was no real
mass weapons of mass destruction.
We know for a fact they, well,
I mean just the fact that everybody's
like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, whatever.
Keep going forward. Like we're
not addressing that because Joe,
we have to focus on the important things.
Killing funding for
planned parenthood and,
and early education because we have
to do some serious cuts. We have to,
we can only drop so many
billion dollar bond, isn't it?
The government like shut down right now.
Is there no government?
Is this a part of Armageddon? Is this
just one more thing? Like those dolphins,
Dolphins died all in 2012 I thought
like the Mayans just got lazy and they
didn't want to count anymore.
They're like, fuck it. All right.
Much more complicated than that.
It's way more complicated based
on that procession of the equinox.
It's based on a 26,000 year cycle, but
you know, it doesn't mean that the,
it's the end of the world.
That's the crazy thing is that nowhere
in the Mayan calendars does it say,
then it sends the end of the low
long count. It's, it's a new era.
That doesn't mean anything. It could just
mean that, you know, generally speaking,
humanity like develops in cycles,
you know, that's what the uh,
the Hindus believe to the Uga is the
whole idea of the Yugas that there are
cycles of humanity and then we eventually,
just by virtue of our design,
we get to a point of laziness and sloth
once we have it all down, you know,
like we do today.
Right.
And then eventually it would spiral out
of control and then be the dark ages
again. Well, I,
they were heading towards the dark ages
or like trans is one of the two or both.
Right. Fucking you,
you hoarding, you know,
all the automation and the inside some
gigantic electric city where everyone's
in some hive mind state just called
this guy on barbarians outside the gate.
I mean you, even if you connect to
the hive mind, I mean if they're,
if that does happen, it's, transhumanism
actually does manifest itself.
We're still going to have people
that are living in Guam, right.
How are we going to get them
and put chips in them? Nope.
But they're going to be used to mind
than is necessary to make the chips.
That's how some of them,
but in the Pacific islands is going to
go and kidnap him and we're going to
enslave them.
Is it going to be some Terminator Shit?
Who's going to be some people?
I think there's still going to be live
in old school no matter what you do.
I met some of those guys.
I met a group of ex Vietnam vets in the
Emerald Triangle that are living in his
box canyon, uh, northern California.
It says, oh, that's a where the county,
it's where they grow the dog.
So what happened?
So I'm up there and I'm
chatting with this guy,
be e Smith who's an ex Vietnam vet.
Uh,
he was the first guy busted
by the feds after, uh,
after it was like legal statewise and
he's growing in a box canyon like 17 other
ex Vietnam vets. There's not, it's
only one road in one road out.
It takes like two hours to drive it.
And they all live there in a community
growing acres and acres of weed.
And are they doing it legit or they're
doing it like on the sneak tip did it's
weight.
I've interviewed so many people about
this and even the most legit guys have
some shady shit going on. It still
seems like no matter what loopholes,
they try to pretend they're exploiting
or we take donations and we're a
caregiver dude.
You have some shady shit your past and
you have two sets of books like every
other dispensary operator out there.
So don't, don't preach thou thank you.
Fucking up the cause here. These
guys under the bus. Here's the thing.
No one going to the camping trips with
these dudes. I, I love the cause, but I,
I do not like people. There's nothing
wrong with wanting to get fucking baked.
There's nothing wrong with weed. What is
wrong? Or people that are cooperating,
the medicinal marijuana movement
and claiming that they're just,
they're just stoners that are trying to
make money or like getting loaded and
they're pretending it's their medicine.
And I'm like, you know, there's no,
that's me. Yeah. Are you, are you
claiming it's medicine? I need it. Right.
Why can't you just like to get high? I do
that. I'll do that. Do what it's about.
I'm seeing all I agree with you.
I know what you're saying.
I'm going to these conventions and seeing
these guys that have like new, like,
oh yeah, sativa, Ben Wa balls. No, it's
the coolest medication you'll ever get.
It's like you're just found
out a new way to get ripped.
Ron High for your asshole.
Don't pretend that a sativa Ben Wa balls.
It's just something you just made up,
but I'm sure it exists. He awesome.
If it was real, if a.com is
available, let's go down here.
This is belladonnas new video.
It's a Tiva Ben Wa balls.
The way to Keester everything
from champagne ecstasy to,
I'm sure there's a video online of
a young lady, I think it's hurting.
Youtube name is neuro soup,
and she took DMT up her ass.
DMT Up. Your ass absorbs directly
into the bloodstream like,
like DMT needed to get any harder. If
you could do that, if you use snort it.
You know what? I think that the
Internet is going to happen.
Like how the government's going to get
involved and stiff with the doing the
kill switch.
I almost think that they're going to
do what like web hosts have been doing
lately, which is, yeah,
it used to be the old days web
hosts were like unlimited bandwidth,
unlimited this blah blah, blah. At 20
bucks a month. Neutrality. Yeah. Yeah.
And I think the government's just going
to release, Hey, we have internet too.
You don't have to sign up for this
Internet two, but if you want to,
it's like a thousand times faster.
And the only stipulation is because
now web hosts are doing the same thing.
It's like, hey, if you switch
to cloud based servers,
you still get everything else,
but now you have to pay for rent.
But the way they're going to
do that is they're going to,
they're going to turn the internet,
you know now into that with net
neutrality or the lack thereof.
So it's going to be, you pay for
the Internet, you get premium,
super fast bandwidth access to the
stuff we want you to have access to.
How important is the message to people
that we need to keep the Internet free?
It does.
Most people is one of them to be one of
the most important debates of our time.
And the fact that they were
like, I thought Google was
going to be good on this.
I really thought they were going
to be the good guy in the fight.
And the deal that they did with Verizon
and the FCC is insane. It basically says,
listen, your traditional broadband, not
gonna fuck with it bro. Net neutrality.
You are good. Yeah. That wireless
spectrum space, we can
totally clamp that down. Well,
how many people believe wires
are in our future? None.
It's all going high speed wireless and
that's the way it's going to be delivered.
And they're pretending
like, you know, they're,
they're going to totally
clamped down on that.
So you're going to pay for your Internet.
It'll probably be provided wirelessly.
And then if you want access
to really good stuff,
so in a t and t and p a t and
t and being for life, right?
Well,
why concern is censorship.
My concern isn't just over control of
bandwidth and stuff like that. My console,
but control the bandwidth is, it is
you're right, you know, you know? Yeah.
The ability to disseminate information
as quickly as possible is one of the most
important parts about it.
You know,
I think that eventually we're going to
have to figure out how much control we're
going to allow the government to
have over us because you know,
people as a group collectively,
you have to realize that there has
never been one thing in human history
responsible for more access to information
than the Internet and it's because of
the free nature of it.
The fruit that you could put up a website
right now and just put up the craziest
fucking shit you want and people will
go to it and then it gets, oh hey,
check this out and virally.
It spreads.
There's never been anything like
that ever in life except rumors.
Rumors were the only things
that have been spread.
Liz took years to go from
one place to the other.
Now it's instantly the Richard Gere
durable and the but rumor. Right.
That shit was spread over the
whole country. You know, they took,
it took a long ass time
for that to happen. No Pun
intended. Yeah, no pun intended.
But what he's talking about. But that's
the only thing that, you know, the,
the Internet, anything is just like the
Richard Gere dribble up the bud story.
Any literally anything can
be any new item that happens,
like literally gets to your Twitter.
Like almost instantly,
like my Twitter is responsible for like
80% of the shit I read online is like
someone tweets me stuff,
you know, like, dude,
you gotta check this out and it's
now and I just retweet it back.
It's like people are tweeting
me the most fascinating shit.
If I lived 30 years ago,
this would never happened.
You would have to live in a university
town and you'd have to either teach or
you'd have to be around students all the
time or you'd have to be in some sort
of a really challenging job where the
other people that are around you were like
really creative and constantly
reviewing information. Right.
In order to get this kind of a kind
of a richness in like what comes in,
you know,
we were so lucky man.
And yet I'd save what 7% of Internet
users take advantage of that. You know?
And that's, that's the hardest part
and now it's being, it's so convoluted.
You have no idea where that information
is coming from. Is it remotely reliable?
Internet is just a, it's a,
it's a, it's also a clusterfuck.
It is tricky because there was
one thing that I read yesterday,
it was a really fucking for,
there's a couple that I've read
but there's one about this.
This is the FBI freedom
of Information Act.
Oh that website we can go and see all the
articles that up there at printed this
one cause it's ridiculous. Is the
guy named Guy Hotel, h o, t, t,
e l I believe is his name.
And Yeah.
And he put out some fucking freedom of
information act thing about Ufo shows,
man.
But listen what it says,
an investigator for the air force stated
that three so-called flying saucers had
been recovered,
had been recovered in New Mexico.
They were described as being circular in
shape with race enters approximately 50
feet in diameter. Each one was occupied
by three bodies of human shape,
but only three feet tall, dressed in
metallic cloth or a very fine texture.
Each body was bandaged. Uh, in a
major, it's, it's hard to read the,
of blogging to the blackout suits
used by speed flyers and test pilots.
This is, uh, some pretty crazy shit.
I don't know if this is a hoax.
I don't know if this is horse shit.
What year was this?
It happened in 1949.
1950 Roswell at the talking about,
or yeah. Yeah. A bunch
of midgets out made.
Just try and take over the world,
crashing their shit.
I just don't know if this is for shit,
but it is on the FBI fucking page.
It's on the FBI. Um, it's, it's the, the,
the page on this guy.
I mean,
all it's saying is that investigator
said that someone said something that
really says, I imagine that if there was,
if that was any more concrete of proof,
it wouldn't be out there. So that's
one of my favorite stories, man.
The Roswell stories.
One of my favorite stories because
it's pretty universal that everyone saw
something and it just,
so many people like General Phillip Corso
and these or as admiral and whenever
the fuck isn't title is, but um, all these
people that were in the military that,
that saw things and testified after the
fact and their stories are so similar,
you know, and you know, after
like 10, 20, 30 years go by,
who the fuck knows what you're really
remembering right now? Who the fuck knows?
I mean there's, you pick up a piece from
someone else's story and yeah, I mean,
you talked to Oj Simpson right now,
that guy do it.
He might have some crazy fucking story
in his head where he really didn't do it.
I mean, who knows? But um,
this New Mexico thing, to me,
it's fascinating because they printed in
the paper that we've recovered a crash
flying desk, you know, that the air
force had communicated to the newspaper.
We have recovered a UFO.
Like it doesn't mean it wasn't
some sort of a Russian thing.
It doesn't mean it wasn't one of their
own things because it also doesn't mean
it wasn't a fucking flying saucer
or there, you know, who would,
who was saying all this like maybe the
reporter just like asked some dummy that
was like, yeah, I saw an alien. Um, I
could tell you because I have it in the,
in the hallway.
I have the actual thing frame for
article because it's fascinating. But no,
it was,
uh,
it was a high level guy and then the next
day he had to come out and do a press
release and they brought like pieces of
a balloon of weather balloon wreckage
and they were saying, oh, this,
it was just this stuff up.
I used to do a joke about it, you
know, they said, what about the aliens?
All those were Mexicans. There were up in
a balloon. They were drinking something,
shenanigans took place. Apparently there's
mistook the balloon for Upenn, Yada,
nothing to worry about it by the way.
We've just invented transistors,
but very little research.
I've never heard that.
It's an old one. Yeah.
Yeah. That was my, um,
the crashed Ufo that they've recovered
now. The Roswell thing is that that was,
yeah, that's an 99. That's a
go along with my settee. One,
the said he wanted to live like,
takes like 3 million years for a signal
radio signal reach outside the galaxy.
So you send out hello? Is anyone out there
3 billion years later? What? Oh yeah,
man,
that's been a while.
I do the Seti search at home where
your computer would help analyze data.
They got back to try to thought
about doing it, but I'm like,
you're just going to hog up my
fucking computer. Shit ever.
I do listen. If they want to talk to
us, they can talk to a stupid, you know,
I mean that's dumb. You know,
the idea that, you know,
we need to sit around monitoring
some fucking radio spectrum.
I think that if anything is going to be
able to communicate with us from that
far away, they're going to
be so fucking far advanced.
All you'd have to do is be in a different
environment where you don't have the
threat of asteroidal impact.
That's it. That's the big one,
asteroid impact and a stable
planet, a planet that, you know,
it doesn't have all the crazy
shit going on at this point.
It does with super volcanoes and shifting
of the polar ice caps and stuff like
that now, which you know, we know happen.
I do get the notion of of listening
though for the same way that we might be
broadcasting something out. Like if
you're going to roll your dice, yes,
they're probably busy,
millions of light years ahead of
us in advanced and intelligent,
but at least common denominator.
Maybe there's another human being species
out there that is still broadcasting.
I love Lucy episodes and Olympic
opening and you can listen for that.
I get that notion. Yeah,
I get the notion too,
but I feel like if you're going to
get to us, they're going to get to us.
It just seems like I w I
loved the uh, woman who, uh,
the Jodi foster movie contact with
based on fascinating that woman,
the woman is really doing that.
She was really out there in the middle
of the fucking desert that don't we need
an alien attack, like nothing.
Nothing too drastic to happen,
but just a common enemy to unite us all.
So we'll realize that we are human beings.
We can all band together.
Then we could really research them.
Cool space travel shit and telephone
orders or whatever else we need.
The most trippy thing would be if we
realize that aliens came from not another
planet, but another
dimension, oh, from here,
but in another dimension that they were
dimensional travelers. And you know,
the concept of dimensions is
pretty fucking squirrely to people.
But I always try to explain it
as if it's a radio, think of it,
life life has a radio and we are
currently tuned in to 97.1 it doesn't mean
there's not a one on 1.1 right down
the dial. That's just as vibrant.
We just haven't tuned into it.
We're just not picking up that frequency.
That's very possible,
isn't that what they were trying to
achieve with the Hadron collider is
obviously studying black holes
and whatnot. But the, the,
the notion that they could
control that explosion,
like if they built one in space,
they could control the explosion in that
explosion would actually be a portal or
a wormhole. Wow. I don't know
about that. I know that the,
the black hole thing was sort of the,
that's sort of residual effect of trying
to create the Higgs Boson particle.
And if what that is,
is a particle theoretical particle that
only existed in milliseconds after the
Big Bang, which is also theoretical.
Right. You know, so they're,
what they're basically doing is seeing
what happens in the extreme conditions of
the universe and trying to
recreate it. You know, it's a,
it's a trippy thing
because, you know, the, the,
the idea is that they're
not going to stop with this.
The idea is whatever findings they learned
from the large Hadron collider will
be applied to the next, to
the next giant device. I mean,
when they first came up with a atomic
bombs, you know, that was, that was the,
the peak of science.
And since then it's accelerated and
gotten bigger and crazier and there's some
shit I'm sure that they're working on
right now that we can't even wrap our
heads around. Like when you, when you,
when you hear about quantum computing
or you're a computer guy, you're,
you're a geek squad, you're
a geek web number. Yeah,
you're a bad mother
fucking fix your modem.
When you hear about quantum computing,
I have tried to,
I've read many papers on quantum
computing. Can I take a deep breath?
And I read them again and I take a deep
breath and I read them again and I try
to wrap my fucking brain around
exactly what they're saying.
But it's so squirrelly. It's like, Whoa,
this is getting awful lot like magic.
You know, this is the APP and it's,
I mean that's, but it's not magic.
That's exactly notion that they're,
but they're also going
to control at biology,
they're going to wrangle cells to do
calculations instead of silicon reading,
artificial leaves.
If you seen that this is the latest thing,
they've created an artificial leaf
that actually has actual artificial
photosynthesis. Wow. That's
amazing. Future of power. And
it's too, yeah, the future.
I love that. I love that. You
know, I thought disasters and drip,
not to bring this to a much lighter note,
but I thought disasters in Japan would
lead to a finely intelligent adult
conversation.
Although I hate the term adult
conversation about energy in this country.
I thought maybe we'd get us to solar
and looking into photosynthesis and all
this stuff, and you know
what? It's done. It's done.
Started a scare fucking scare tsunami.
You know,
this whole country is
terrified in Orange County.
There's a fault line and there's
a new global higher boom.
We're doing what happens.
That's what everybody should find about
scared by nuclear energy. That's great.
But channel that paranoia into creating
positive technologies instead of relying
on coal and deep sea drilling, see
that would require enlightenment. Ah,
and we are children. Human beings are
as childish as we are allowed to be.
You know? And I, I see that every
day. I see that in having kids.
I see that in just in human
being and lazy behavior.
People are as childish and
indulgent as they have to be.
And that's why we're so fascinated when
we hear about some Amazon tribe that
goes out and gets their own fucking
water with hollowed out coconuts and you
know, they fucking shoot monkeys would
spear guns and that's what they eat.
You know, like you, you read about
that and you go, Whoa, how resourceful.
Like what a grind they're putting.
Like there's no room for
laziness and that culture,
like these motherfuckers are out there
doing it because we know what the
possible with human beings, but we
also know how we are inclined to sloth.
You know, it's like, it's so easy
for people to just be like, Ooh, Ooh,
Ooh boots. Fug It's, you know,
it's so easy. It's so easy
to think like, I'm sorry,
it's just,
I have listened.
I was watching a video of a guy squat
on a mason jar and it popped in his ass.
Uh, what were you saying about what we
say? That's the most disturbing thing.
I think I've ever seen that one guy.
One Jar.
Love it right up there with Mr
Hands. It's right up there. Um,
have we touched on, uh, well you,
you mentioned something earlier that I
wanted to get back to about what would we
as a society, society is sick bay, except
from our government in terms of control,
revolt and all this stuff.
And I'm still amazed every damn flight
I take when I look at the TSA procedures
and I see people just standing in those
x ray boxes and just filling their
bodies with gamma rays to
prove that they're not a
terrorist. What do you do? Do,
do opt out? Not opt out. Really? Yeah. You
got a patent down there, man. Absolutely.
Wow. There was just a study recently
that they have to retest a whole bunch of
machines because it was
like 47% was the number,
more radiation was coming out per
machine than what they estimated.
I don't need some dude getting a fucking
image of myself on some box that he
could send around. I don't know.
You know, and I don't think that,
I would never lie. I, I, if I
were, if I were hung any better,
I would be in jail because I would
show it off every five seconds. And I
constantly, constantly depressed at
the sad state of affairs down there
dozer guy with a micro penis that I got
in an argument with about male feminism.
Yeah. And a long story. But the
point is that, you know, it's,
it's become like a point of debate where
like some guys have been upset at me.
Like what is your,
your issue with male feminism?
My issue is the same thing as women
that are masculine Isms, you know,
or masculine aesthetic, you know,
any women who is only in demand,
like men power and man power globally or
even into it to the point where you're
promoting it.
Just promote equality amongst human beings
as far as the way we treat each other.
But there's something creepy
about mayor fee, male feminists.
And that's why I wanted
you to pull up that video.
Brian and I tweeted this yesterday,
it's by these guys that called
themselves the conscious men. Okay.
And it is like an apology
and a like a a manifesto.
I'll read the description on
behalf of men or apology to women,
apology to women and on behalf of men
to women because they are conscious and
they were trying to get in touch
with their femininity. They are.
I've never seen a bigger group of w w
look like date rapists and creeps and and
just uh, knowing fucking weak ass bitches.
Have you been to comicon? No, I haven't.
Okay. Is it different? Is it worse?
Watch this though. You must do this.
You have to see this for, for,
for folks listening, listening,
don't listen to me no matter what I
say. Listen, even if you agree with me,
I'm an idiot.
Listen,
listen to this band before you.
Today as men committed to becoming more
conscious in every way we feel deep
love, great respect, and are
growing. By the way, the man talking,
his name is gay Hendricks.
We also feel deep sorrow about the
destructive actions of the unconscious
masculine in the past and present.
We want to apologize and make amends for
those actions today so that we can move
forward together into a
new era of the pink spoon.
What does he know what that is?
That's a fountain. Like they're calm.
They're enlightened skill.
Why listen to the music and then
she to me in you in all of life,
I know that we all have access to
the full spectrum of these energies.
If you see this guy, you
realize how fucking creepy
the sound's going. Awareness.
There's gotta be a vital for
skittles, hold humanities. I admit it.
I can only think about Kevin
ribbon and living in [inaudible].
I can work with a mass with the music
I'd play. When you look at these,
look at these.
I know that in order to truly honor
you as a multidimensional a woman,
I must add fully present and and
the gifts. I bought drugs from him.
Absolutely.
I look at this guy,
rapist and your train each other in a
conscious way. Clearly leaders' eyes.
He's got an ankle bracelet specs and by
worshiping at affinity expressed with
the masculine and the feminine energies,
that Guy's full of shit.
That guy's just looking for blessing.
Look at his little smile at the end
has often been unconscious. I feel so.
These all look like people that
went to a camp to pray the gay away.
This guy's reformed. He's totally
into pussy now. Yeah, from wicker man.
It's a woman burning at the stake.
It's like women burning. Get the cross.
Here's what you don't understand that
Bernie, the crossing was explained,
relegated you to subservient chores,
force you to hide your faces and even
cut off your organs of sexual pleasure.
That I
get a little extreme that I'm aware of.
The forces at the unconscious,
masculine psyche, pouty of
masculine psyche.
Many of the men who have appraised this
guy's mastering my psyche and its mouth
for a lot among the living.
Many men may not be able to apologize
because they remain shock called and a
prison of anger. Fear.
You're a shitty poet, dude.
Be Half of my gender to you.
Don't you say shit.
When we were angry,
scared,
and when the grip of destructive forces
in our psyche and I choose to no longer
contribute to those forces,
I just noticed room smells
like it's wooden paneled
and the tears in the biology
smells like faggotry Snodgrass,
Star Poker player guy.
Is this the most ridiculous shit ever?
Thousand Years I've been mainly founded
by this guy who propagated by men.
We've often activism Brody Stevens and
God and the spiritual life and all.
We have visits with an invite and you
guys got to emit an invite to a Trump
circle is this big contest they need.
Just got done selling meth,
inclusive spirituality
to honoring the stayed
away from the devil.
Hardly I honor your deep
connection to the earth.
Oh, how's man? Right, so I had an Innie
now was that the point? All of these guys,
it just crawled back into my stomach.
All you guys are willing to
roofie you domination who stay.
Can we believe that expansion to protect
us from encroachment and in the process
we violated the sanctity of
yours. Okay. Start with it's math.
I can't even watch it.
I understand that they have good
intentions and I'm sure they're not really
rapists,
but you've got to understand folks,
you all what we would classify as weak
ass bitches and that's why you're feeling
this way and that's why you're feeling
like you need to go out and save the
world and make these women look.
Women are going to be fine. Yeah.
Would be nice to women. Absolutely.
Other than making youtube,
they're trying to look cool.
They're trying to,
they're trying to get really
broken women to like them.
You know the kind of women that look,
they can't attract them.
They're not interesting. They're probably
not successful than not intelligent.
They're not swole,
they're not sexually attractive.
They probably have nothing going on.
No.
Puts them in a diaper
in a cage and whip them.
I don't even think that
that would be too exciting.
They have less than that and they,
I think to have that,
I think that pay for that.
We're not the nose.
I think you just fucking
speculating at this point,
aren't we all but the world here,
right? Let's speculate away.
But what they are is weak ass
bitches and we don't need that. Well,
the those men need is stakes and
squats and bootcamp and, and, and,
and someone who gets them
a fucking interest, get
whatever the fuck it is, man.
So let's make an apology video on behalf
of men for them. And it should be,
that's what it should be. We should
dear we gas of the world, dear women,
dear women who have been,
you know,
compromised by these knuckleheads to
try to pretend that men aren't men and
women aren't women and there's some
sort of a hybrid that you can be, well,
you can appeal to the women and embrace
your feminine energy. Dear rude,
I'm sorry you've had a crate and barrel
magazine Humping Douche bag to walk over
your whole life. But I promise
I will waltz into your bedroom,
choke you during climax and
probably spent in your mouth.
If you can't gorilla fucker check,
you better know some poetry
and that's the reality.
You better know how to write
some shit down and make it rom.
You better know what kind
of flowers she likes.
You better be good at massages
and if you're lucky, Shelia,
and should probably barely be wet sand.
She's not really into
dude cook our salmon,
but her trainer might fuck the shit
out of her. I'll tell you that.
Her training my fucker in a parking lot,
man,
he might just whip out his fucking hog
and a parking lot. You never know, man.
Right on the polities. Machino why?
Here's why. You're ready. You're ready?
We're animals. Okay? We're not
perfect. Yeah, we're evolving. Yeah,
it's the ideal is great. Be Be, be
nice to people. That's all good.
But here's what you also have to do.
You gotta be a fucking man.
If you want women to like you,
you gotta be a man.
That's why you don't like dykes. Why do
you not like tags? Because they're weird.
It's not like this is not being there,
not being a woman. It's not. It's not.
Even though she's a woman.
What's not sexy about it? Well,
there's some weird thing there. She's
acting like a man. Well, guess what?
Fuck head women think the same way
about men who act like women. All right?
Men want women. Women want men.
It's really that God damn simple.
You can't be some fucking hybrid
to fill in the gaps and, and take,
you can't actually do whatever
the fuck you want to do. I mean,
who am I to tell you?
But you know,
you're just going to get you
to set up all to where you can.
You can actually create the gap for
yourself. You want to live in chastity?
Bono can do it. She's a
man now. I just got to,
I thought it was the girlfriend telling
me to shut the fuck up and she said
right on. And I was like, okay, cool. She
sends you a text. She texts him and shit.
Oh No, I love that. How long you been
dating a girl? Uh, I officially about
two years now. [inaudible]
your pimp music. So did you
never dated a living man?
Mom, you were dating the
whole time. Then another girl,
what'd you call the Mun Dickson.
His mouth.
Were you when that apology video?
I think a lot of things.
I think a lot of the Internet always,
I was kind of jealous of you
or never dated. Never dated,
never messed around everyday.
That's a distinctly different things
that I think I have pretty lucky to do.
You can't, you cannot mix,
you cannot mix those cards.
You got to treat them like
they're your sisters man.
I'd never had a sister and I swear to
God by the end of that run I was like,
I know exactly what it's like to have
a sister. Absolutely felt that way.
What does she smell like?
Vaginas and flowers,
dreams wishes burnt salmon,
salmon.
But you've been really successful over
at GE four they eat that whole network.
Pretty much centers
around a couple of people.
You and extended play people or
whatever it's called nowadays.
But uh,
how did you even fall into that?
Because I mean when I first moved
to California, I had no friends,
zero friends and it was when the screen
savers just moved to La and pretty much
I had nothing to do at no friends.
So I would just go to live
tapings all the time just for fun.
Cause that was a cool show.
Yeah.
So I got to hang out with like the Kevin
Rose and Yoshi and all of them and I,
it was the only thing I did.
And how did you,
you were kind of looked at as the bad guy,
I guess if you have a tech
TV side of things. We were,
I was somehow lumped into the evil empire
that came and absorbed this network
and explained to everybody who doesn't
know the history. All right. Uh,
so there was a network called tech
TV based out of San Francisco,
which I was a huge fan of super.
Nowadays screensavers call for help.
And what was the dude with the white
hair that would review Game Leo? No,
you're talking to Adam Sessler.
Yeah,
he's still on g four is
annex PLO game show Megan.
But there was this weird
sort of buy out of TV.
It wasn't like some hostile
takeover or anything like that. And,
and unfortunately I think that at
the time the merger was mismanaged,
it was sort of like,
well I think network interests were buying
distribution and not buying content.
And that was the problem. And so
it was just sort of like, okay,
we have all this distribution now,
let's just merge these networks and
we'll figure it out and let it fly.
And so unfortunately I got stuck in a
situation where they were transitioning a
show that I loved the screensavers and
to this other show without thinking that
the audience might not like that you turn
on the dial one day and it's the same
time, the same kind of program, but it's
a different name with, with some of the,
some of the nerdiest stuff
stripped out and all that stuff.
And so it got a lot of bad blood,
which unfortunately still exists
today on the Internet. Like I get it.
I always tell people when I meet them
that were tech TV fans that go like
screensavers, I go, listen dude,
I love that show too. You know,
and I hope that people realize
now it is a different show.
And unfortunately the transition was
rough and awkward and I still take lumps
for it all the time when I go out and
be upset about the most, like you said,
the geekier elements were to walk away.
They took away everybody, all the,
the people that we like.
One of the coolest thing is,
is that before it all happened, the
screensavers, he used to have webcams,
they just put all webcams in and the
day it happened, Alex put on this image,
which is, uh, Alex say goodbye
everyone. Yeah. And, and it,
it pretty much everyone on the
Internet found out about it first.
What's crazy is though I had the same
hat as him and the same shirt as him.
So I put,
I put tss is canceled under it and I had
the same outfit and same hat on there
and that got around the Internet.
So everyone thought at
first the screensaver was
canceled and stuff like that.
And just do that as a scam, a
troll as a troll and then, and then
you don't know how fucked up this guy is.
Let me,
let me show you one of the things
that he did. You fortunate he owned,
he owned Pepsi spice.com. Okay.
When Pepsi Spice came out,
Pepsi spice was like this innovative new
beverage. It's Pepsi, but it's spicy.
Well this asshole found out that Pepsi
spice hadn't gotten a their own domain.
They didn't secure the domain.
So Brian starts a daily blog on Pepsi
spice about going on Pepsi's Bisoli Diet
and he, he, he starts only
allowed to drink Pepsi.
Deteriorate your body straight.
Fucking horrible. Tell
people what, is it still up?
Uh, no, I took it down
cause I was, Pepsi is there,
they're going to sue me or something
like that. But, but it lasted that,
I said in 30 days only going to have
Pepsi spice. So it started off where,
you know, the first couple of days I'm
like, I'm really hungry, but you know,
whatever.
Then I started getting like open sores.
I was fucking pissed and blood
and then it got too bad where I'm,
my Dick is falling off. I was losing like
10 pounds a day or something like that.
This is like 2000 right? Yeah. This was,
this was a while ago. A long time ago.
It was probably like 2004 or something
like that. Was it 2004 were you here?
I was here when it had nothing to
do except go to the screensavers.
I'll get her. But, but what's crazy
is that I even had radio interviews,
they interviewed me on radio stations
because they thought it was real and then
it started, Pepsi started getting
contact and he's saying, you know,
they're threatening me.
So I had to kind of,
I made my character
die and I took it down.
But you could find this
stolen Google cache and stuff.
But you know what the other thing does
that work? What does Google cache work?
Google cache is kind of like what's, you
know, RSS feeds. They grab your website,
RSS feed,
they go out and they crawl your site.
You put it out there and not say crawl
your page is looking for key words and
images of whatever their caching,
all that shit.
They're saving the whole Internet
saved kind of to an extent. Yeah.
They really kind of do a lot of
broken images though, but sure. Yeah,
definitely on the
Internet way back machine,
the Internet archive wayback machine is
so fun. You can go ahead and go work.
It saves kind of thing based off
the cash at safe snapshots of sites.
There's broken images and whatnot,
but you can go back and look
at Yahoo back in the day.
If you went home website
and go back and look at it,
they can still do your website
98 that was my first website.
Thank God youtube wasn't yet.
You're almost 10 years old.
You're old websites on there. Yeah, me
too. Oh, you're what sites on there,
but this is a question
I wanted to ask you,
cause you used to work with
Laura Foi or yeah, it was.
I was for slash Laura Foy,
who's a really hot blonde chick that
used to be on a really cool show with uh,
Scott Rubin and Tina Woods. It's
called g four tv.com. Anyways,
she forgot one day.
That's her webcam.
Then it's like right
when they put on webcams.
So I caught her all these times just
sucking her thumb and she didn't know the
Webcam was on. Is this something they
see like openly did around the office?
Because I even got photos of her when
she found out that the Webcam was used to
do,
do what you're supposed to do.
Dude is not let that out and find her,
but a honey on your dick or do you
remember what I don't think. I don't.
I think fully,
I would rather have the thumb sucking
photos online then suck honey off a member
personally. No, no. That
might be really into that.
I'd be willing to put money on
it. You're so wrong. A guarantee.
You can test the in front
of a Webcam. Come on, dude.
She's hoping the FBI's tuning into that,
sending that message.
We referred her fucking thumb. You're
sucking a cock. Okay. If you're not three,
he's talking to cock.
Remember when cats Swartz put out a
bunch of photos and then somebody learned
about the thumbnail being saved in
Photoshop. Now what are you talking about?
Who's cats for cans? Sports used to
be also on the screen savers. Playboy.
I personally signed pink slips or some
shit that was due to that right there.
I didn't see that. She used to also
someone's little sends to their faults.
You are reacting to all the fun,
the vial from the Internet.
I'm actually pretty good friends with,
I'm friends with cat and her baby's daddy
and everything that baby's daddy works
for South Park and that's how she,
that girl that was on,
she did playboy or something? No,
no, no. This is what she did. She,
she released some photos of herself,
like model photos and there were not,
not not new photos taken.
But what happens is like
when you put in Photoshop,
it saves like a thumbnail of the photo,
like inside,
like the information of the data
insight, the photo, like the,
like each photo has data in it.
Like a lot of times it has gps
information or it has camera.
It was taken on with the settings where
there's extra data in addition to just
the image. So they, she cropped it
before she put it on the Internet.
But what it's saved the
original as a thumbnail.
So when she released all these photos,
people found out that they
opened it up in Photoshop.
The preview showed the full original
photo of her naked and so there was all
these photos of cat naked,
which was awesome for it.
Kind of like Paris Hilton to her career,
but they were not,
some of them were not the most flattering.
Explain this to me again.
What happens is the original
images were like Photoshop.
Photoshop had a feature where you could
like publish a web gallery, you know,
publish it directly to the web. I think
that's the, it's been a long while,
but I think that's how the story went.
So it actually published layers that
were shut off and she had cropped one and
again,
like the thumbnail was sort of saved of
the full image even though she cropped
it within the program.
So how would they access it?
They opened it up in Photoshop to look
at it in the information transferred over
in Photoshop so you can see the preview.
I said.
Then she just pretty much
leaked all these naked justice,
sue the fuck out of Photoshop for her own
benefit. It benefited. There was us,
there was a program that would look at
people's photo bucket accounts back in
the day and then PR procedurally changed
the file names looking for files that
were sort of hidden or not publicized
and so many girls had private photos that
they were storing are sending to their
right as long distance boyfriend exposed
by crawling that there were so many
cool things back in the day when the
Internet was still like,
people are still figuring out
the barrier to entry was high,
the Internet was fucking dope. Like I'll
never forget the bulletin board Danes,
we had to like know how to do a dial out
telex program and call some shady dudes
computer in a basement who was hosting
porn and where's games and all that stuff
we were talking about, which are well
and good, but this is way better today.
That's all nine science.
It's very nostalgic to go back to
those bulletin board days on a 1440
[inaudible] be and I would hear those
noises and immediately get erect.
Yeah, I knew that porn was
coming, right. We do do,
remember we were talking about wet
tricks that we are both Dreamcast fans,
but I remember going on like AOL message
boards and stuff and getting all like
every single video game possible burnt
onto a disk and that was IRC for that.
What's the best for dream cast
if we're going to IRC rooms,
that's where the real creepy shit.
I used to be a big quick player so I
used to get on the IRC or were you in the
room and they released Q test one
will know that was a quick one.
I wasn't a big one too.
Yeah,
and I followed it through quick three
and into quick fourth quick fours.
One to really have to stop. Now it's
like quake arena on a web browser. Yeah,
quick arenas is shit. All of it. It's
fucking fun as hell man. But it's all,
it's just super time consuming.
We've talked about it a hundred times on
this podcast, the drinking game. Quick,
quick, quick, quick, quick, quick.
Ha Ha. Blacking out drunk now
the next thing you know, so Google TV
did. Tell me about yes, please get in on,
explain me this amazing.
We were in the kitchen.
You pop this up and I made you stop
talking to them like this is too good.
Threatened me with a butter
knife. I'm like, I have to stop.
We need to talk about this on a podcast.
Uh,
Google is gonna try to own the living
room and it's going to be them apple,
potentially Comcast,
Time Warner and a few others that are
really going to be making the play for
being the gateway to media and Google is,
Google is crushing it right now.
Basically Google TV,
you can buy,
I have the Logitech revue box
and it has an HD my pass through.
What does that mean? That means if you
have a cable box or a satellite box,
you connect that instead of going
directly to the TV or receiver,
you plugged that into the
Logitech tech box, right.
Then that goes to your TV and
what that does, what that does,
which no other box really does,
is it gives you ability to layer
information on top of your TV.
All these other boxes.
You've got to switch to another input
and you lose the TV side of things and
it's a different experience. Then
you go back to your TV. This one,
at any given time, you have
an argument about, oh, what
was that actor in that one?
Boom.
You hit the search button on your iPhone,
your android phone or the keyboard,
type it in,
there's indb up and running while your
stuff's in a picture. In picture window,
you want access to podcast and video cast.
You hit the home button,
go to their spotlight.
Uh,
there's actually a website that's doing
an app where you watch models go down a
runway and it tells you about like the
fashion they're wearing and if you want,
you click press okay and it pulls up the
website while the video is still going.
You can order it right from wow on
your team, on your TV and it's got a full
wet. The box is a little underpowered.
It's like a little net book in there.
It's a little underpowered.
But this as a step one is fucking,
is there a one that's coming out soon?
That's the better one, or is there
a better Google TV than the other?
Like there's this stolen one the best.
I think the logic is a little better than
the Sony because of the remotes in the
end, the apps themselves, right,
but as long as content providers don't
completely fuck this platform over which
they're trying to do left and right,
because they're also scared,
it will be amazing. How are they trying
to fuck over by blocking their content?
Who's some basically doing this? I don't
know if I can name names, name names.
Let's start a fucking revolution. I'll
tell you what. I'll tell you what.
I wanted to watch a south park episode
the other day and I went and pulled up
south park's website and now again,
if I had my laptop,
I can pull it up right there and watch
the full high def south park episode,
sit through commercials or whatever.
The right there.
When I tried to pull it up on my
TV, it popped up and said, oh,
you're trying to access this
from a Google TV device. Sorry,
is that Comcast your block right
now? No, that's it was south park.
So I think that's Viacom.
I think I'm safe to make fun of them,
but it also did that on blocks. So does
Hulu, which is fucking frustrating. Oh,
that's suing because the same ads that
they're their, their, their worry is that,
you know,
the Google experience is too good.
You're sitting on your couch and this
content that's for free on the Internet,
it's easily accessible. And I go, well,
it's the same ads and the same content
that I'd have if I turned over here.
If you had a Mac mini hooked up your TV
and use my laptop or using my whatever,
someone over there is not getting it, you
know, I'm willing to sit through the ad.
I'm willing to to make
it worth your while.
It's like when I try to go watch a movie
these days, I don't know if you've like,
I tried to legally acquire content
now actually tried it the other day.
I wanted to watch Jurassic Park,
so I checked my Xbox,
I checked my video on demand, I checked
the Sony Network, I check Netflix,
I checked Amazon. I went through service
after service and finally said, fuck it.
I went and looked at bit torrent.
There was the high def rip,
there was the Blue Ray
repp with all the extras.
I clicked and an hour later
I'm watching it on my TV.
I tried to give somebody
money for that movie.
He's never [inaudible] was
unable to happen to me.
It's basically the old guard that hasn't
really accepted the new technology,
this new thing, and they're scared of it
and we drastic park. That's ridiculous.
Well,
I mean that's why I'm like drastic part.
That should be on Netflix streaming.
That shouldn't. Yeah, exactly.
I mean that should be everywhere. It's
incredible. When you get Google TV, man,
it will. It will sound right
to you. It's that good.
It's really that good and
it's very frustrating that
people are blocking content
though. It's super frustrating. Let
me look. There's ways around it,
but is there a reason? Do they
have a legitimate argument? Well,
Zero Bill Burr RSS Feed interactions.
No, there's nothing that makes sense.
Just like that argument. Um, the,
the, they're worried that again,
the experience is too good.
We can't just give that content away.
How can we charge extra for that content?
Like Hulu says they're
working with Google,
they're going to try to charge for Hulu
plus on the Google TV or something like
that. That's fun. It's nickel and diming
left. So you'd have to pay for Google TV.
Do you have a,
is it a subscription based service?
Now see that's the beauty of Google TV
is free itself is terrifying and it's a
great overlay.
We really found out the good
that artificial intelligence
actually does exist.
And what it is is Google and the Google
figured out a way to fucking program the
universe and own everything.
I mean, it's so weird.
I use a government at chrome browser.
I use Gmail. I mean, come on man.
It's going to be apple and Google
and that's going to be the big,
the big fight for all of your data
and all your media access and all your
management. Maybe Google, Amazon. But
fuck, it's going to be right in there.
Did you see the onion bit about Facebook
being created by the CIA as a data
mining tool? No. Fucking brilliant. That's
fun and it basically said that, you know,
Facebook was launched as a secret program
and it took off wildly successful.
They never imagined that citizens would
give up all their photos, their likes,
their dislikes, their check ins,
check outs. It's like, imagine,
forget Google, that's the
data set. That scariest shit.
Google long longitude or whatever
where it just tracks you all day.
That's even worse.
We were talking about lobby view,
longitude and what that is.
What does that,
that's where your phone pretty much tells
you, tells you friends where you are,
exactly where you are.
You could track your girlfriend exactly.
Driving down the street and it's just
sending it to Google. That's a great idea.
Right? It's weird. It's
weird how it's just creepy.
If it leads to better ads in my email,
cool.
But it's just amazing how fucking
ambitious Google is. They're so ambitious.
I mean the do this and the browser
and cars that drive themselves,
aren't they working on an operating
system that they already had the chromium?
It's based on chrome and honeycomb for
tablets, which is going to be awesome.
Like it says, their operating
system is available right now.
You can download chromium for certain
net books. You cannot get right,
and have you tried it? Yeah, it's
not. It's not where it needs to be.
Now the idea is that in the future,
cloud computing is going to lead to,
I mean we're going to laugh at the fact
that this has a processor that has a
processor. That computer behind
you has ram and chips in it.
We're going to laugh at that. What a
waste of resources. It's going to be.
Your phone's going to be
streaming basically. Yeah.
Basically all you need is,
is whatever technology needs to happen
to stream a high def signal at 60 or 30
to 60 frames a second to
whatever device there is.
So the idea is that in the future you'll
have just have a screen or you'll walk
into a hotel, you'll sit at a
terminal, you'll punch in your info,
or it'll scan your retina
or your peanut cup,
however they'll do it and all of a
sudden your desktop appears like that.
All of your shit's on it. You
leave, you pick up your phone,
your desktop appears on it. Like that's,
that's the future of cloud computing.
Everything's going to be stored and
processed in servers that we don't see
because it will be beamed quick enough
and it already exists today and phantoms
going to bring it to fandom.
That was a vapor ware console.
But like if you look at online,
which is a gaming service,
it's not quite there yet,
but the idea is that you buy one box.
Did you guys just get the fuck out? Shit.
Yeah, did right. Phantom was a check.
Phantom was supposed to be a console that
would sit in your living room and pool
games out of the cloud essentially,
and you'd never have to
buy a disk or whatever.
You can play from the comfort of a couch
and it's like streaming video games and
it was fast enough supposedly to be able
to play where there's no drop and frame
rate or you could actually, you
know, and that was all bullshit.
That was all a money laundering scheme.
So subdued could crash Ferrari's
canyon or whatever. Yeah,
there's a company called on
live that is one of many.
There's another APP called [inaudible].
We used it the other day and it's
like it's got its hiccups, but imagine
when you log in a service
you'd see thousands of
windows streaming call of duty
in streaming a gears of war and all this
stuff and you can go and click on it
and those are actually people playing
live and you're spectating all their games
and they're all streaming in real time.
And then if you want to play the game,
they're playing,
you press a button,
it pulls you out of it and launches you
right into that game that exists today.
Now it's not a five out of five just yet.
What is it now for three?
Probably a three, two or three things is
what we gave him. The promise is there.
So that's what Google's
trying to do with chromium.
They're trying to make this operating
system where you don't store shit locally.
It's all Google docs and Google paint and
Google image video editor and all that
shit. It's all going to live in the cloud
and you'll be sure that it's so creepy.
They're right.
They're absolutely right on that one.
You know like Microsoft always creeped
me out to Bill Gates always creeped me
out like any,
anyone who's dad ambitious,
the trying that hard like come on
man, what's going on? Does that,
why does that creep you out? I don't know.
Cause they have so much this assembly,
different products that are so successful.
You're very ambitious. You're no,
not in that way. I don't want to control
anybody else's information. You know
the thing that always bugs me,
like here's a perfect example. Uh,
like the iPad or the
iPhone eight what I made,
I made a video a long time ago where it
pretty much broke down in the one of the
two I iPhones. And you guys actually
played it out on your show where it,
remember when I had the,
I'm an old iPhone and I'm an old cell
phone from three years ago and it was like
I have a cute, yeah. Yeah. It was a pretty
big video and stuff like that, but it's,
it was based on basic things like the
iPad where the first iPad didn't have a
camera. The second one has a
camera and stuff like that.
There's so many things like do you think
that apple is actually doing that on
purpose? Is that a part
of their mark? Totally.
I mean they'll do the research search
and do enough focus groups to find out
what features they have to include to
make it amazing, palatable, magical,
revolutionary, whatever and undergo.
Okay. The next version
we'll have all these things.
Just like when this launched without
picture messaging and all sorts of stuff,
like they know what the consumer
is willing to put up with,
especially those early adopters. Picture
thing was bullshit typing in the code.
That was the most ridiculous thing ever.
And then you'd get like you
go to at and t wireless dot,
whatever and put in this login and this
past and it was a tiny ass little image
too. It wasn't the full
image. It was ridiculous.
It's ridiculous to me and
not to get on a nerdy rant,
but that's all I really have to offer
this world is the fucking fact that if,
let's say I have Verizon and I'm paying
40 bucks a month for their data plan and
18 know better and then if I want to
tether that phone to my laptop to use this
as a modem,
I got to pay an extra fee,
but it's still eats away at the
bandwidth that I'm paying 40 bucks for.
Is that because the FCC and senators
don't realize that it's all the same
bandwidth and no,
I think it's Verizon making money.
It's kind of Shitty with your fucking
that changed at and t does the same.
They charge you extra to tether,
but it's the same bandwidth that I'm
paying monthly for the group to use that
their data serves is not very good.
I had an 18 team phone of iPhone and
then I got a Verizon iPhone recently and
one thing I notice is that I'll have a
full three g signal and Verizon and then
I'll start downloading something,
an app or something and it'll kick off
three g a t t to eight is better than
than Verizon. Have you seen their
LTE network longterm evolution? No.
That shit is fast, faster.
That's where is it? Is it habit?
Verizon's is out team. What? I mean
where can you get it everywhere?
I don't know about here. You can
get in Los Angeles, it's a pretty,
it's pretty common. Spotty spots by the
end of HTCs. Thunderbolts has that right?
That looks pretty bad.
That's bad. I mean like we,
we were a star even in our little studio,
which is like,
it's Kryptonite to all signals.
It's a little shoe box right in there.
The Lte was as fast as the cable
modem was. So the idea is again,
the whole net neutrality
thing that I'm worried about,
like you'll goodbye or like a Verizon
wireless LTE router for your home and
you'll wirelessly pulled down your
bandwidth and share it with everybody else
cause it's that fast now wireless.
Wow.
That's a lot of things that
have to change his cell phone.
So like I had a palm pre plus I
got stuck with, with the Verizon.
I wanted out so bad and it's going
to cost me now $350 to cancel.
And I've had it for a year and a half,
almost a year. And I just want to cancel.
I just, yeah, that phone seem real
promising before it actually came out.
And then I was like, well it's kind of
Shitty and Wong get dropped it a dude.
I got a um, uh, a new droid droid
to global because I want to,
I love Verizon service.
I had a blackberry before and I
wanted to get a Verizon service,
but I wanted it to be global. So I
said, oh well here's the solution.
All these people love the droid.
I mean,
I heard Howard stern talking about
how he loves his joy. I got it.
It's like a drunk, retarded
iPhone. It's like stupid.
And like the,
the first time I used it,
I go to slide the screen to open it
up and it's like, shake, stutter,
shake starter, shake, stutter. I'm
like, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa. Really?
This was the students. It doesn't even
know how to harness how much power it has.
That's the thing.
It's scared by its own ability.
Played with it for 20 minutes and the
battery was half drained and I was like,
you gotta be fucking kidding
me. I mean, that's ridiculous.
Like I can't even fuck around and
just play with it. I went online,
I checked what it looks
like on one websites.
I checked my email 20 minutes
and it was half dead. I was like,
that's just preposterous.
And people are like, oh no,
you go to goodwill or mobile application,
command power command and shut off
this and do this. It's like, oh,
I don't want to hack my devices anymore.
I just want them to work.
And that's the fundamental,
there's so many people that have this
thing about the fucking jail breaking and
that's too complicated.
There's so many people though that
have this anti-apple sentiment.
You know there's a real,
like these threads come up on a message
board all the time and it's so dumb.
It's the dumbest conversation ever.
Everyone was a merger of rugs. That's the,
that's the number one argument match
very of what was fucking fuck and I could
use a merch. I don't know how
to use a real computer, but if,
if you want to bypass the line at the
genius bar, you can by swallowing. Really.
It's a weird, it's a little bit, what
about girls? It's apple care girls.
The genius aren't as I swallow them to
swell, whatever they've got, whatever.
He got the biggest shoot,
hardcore Unix guy,
command lines only switched to windows.
I was a network administrator back in
the day when I switched to Mac. I'm like,
listen, shit works and if I really
want to drill down, get deep,
I can pop open a terminal window
and do whatever I need to do.
The people that are that are anti Mac,
just like the Mac people are anti PC.
It's all fucking students.
A team like this way,
so it's a dumb team thing
and the Max or the liberals,
the Max or the week pussies
and then you know from Max,
the pcs are all Sarah Pailin.
Same thing with consoles like playstation
or it's like fuck you ThreeSixty
fanboy through Xbox owners like
playstations for Douche bags.
It's like no one wants to be wrong.
No one wants to admit that they might've
bought the console that has a problem
or spent money on the
game that had a problem.
You want to be right and it's like,
you know what?
You're not going to be right all the time.
It's with everything.
Protestants versus the Catholics.
That whole Mac versus PC thing.
It's just such a strange one though to me.
I wonder how many people,
like whether they're politicians or
people trying to appeal to a certain class
of society will choose a PC
over a Mac to let you know,
hey, I'm a part of the proletariat.
Like Obama saying, Hey,
I got to my pad when he made a big
deal out of it and like I use an Ipad,
I'm the president of United
States. Must be right. Yes.
Sending messages is they
higher end president?
This is a more connected
and multitouch sensitive.
It was the first president to bring a
laptop to the White House. To you serious?
Yeah. Well I remember he wouldn't
give up his blackberry at the time,
which I thought was cool because
it wasn't secure. You know,
one thing I wish the iPad I was,
I can't believe it doesn't have,
is multiple users. I hate it when people
want it. Like borrow my iPad. I'm like,
okay, I'm logged into Facebook, Twitter,
email, everything. I mean girls, girls,
why does it that, that seems like a
basic thing that I should have by now.
This is what you say. Listen, bitch,
get shown. That's what you gotta say.
You gotta fucker correctly. Okay. Liberal,
panting and sweating. And she goes, can I,
can I use your iPad? You don't
listen bitch. No, I love you.
Get your own fucking iPad. And she'll
giggle and she'll drop it. Why?
Cause you fucked her correctly
Brian. Okay. Is that there
in lies the issue? Yes.
Or get another iPad. You can
have mine. You'd give it to her.
Tell her she can use it.
As long as you're looking over a shoulder
because she's in like a downward dog
position and you're behind her, then you
can play all the fucking dungeon. Ray,
do you want,
did you learn to play the drums using
rock band or have you always been a
drummer? I self taught and
been drumming for awhile.
Have you been in a band before? Several.
Several shitty bands, jazz bands,
hardcore rap, jazz bands, everything.
Really. What kind of jazz? You name it.
I mean we did take five bands have the
biggest percentage of Douche bags in them
up. Music. I mean they all do it.
Just a course on getting douche bag.
You are Christian rock jars.
Claire fuckers shooting rock rules.
Do they all have douchebags in him?
But I mean I think that's the number
one issue though with bands, right?
I mean Eddie Bravo has been
in bands his whole life.
He said the number one issue has always
been dealing with like trying to like
manage all the egos and the band.
It's like hurting cats and that's,
that's what kills so many bands are not
chats. Cats running around like mad,
like the herd cats. That's
perfect. Uh, and, and I,
I've seen that with many bands that
I've been in, but it's, it's just,
and it's fucking hard to
make music these days.
It's as easy as it gets with
distribution and the tools to make it,
it's still really fucking hard
to make a music these days.
Has that always been your dream
to be in a band or what was,
you would put it all in a second.
Yeah.
I'd quit everything in a second to go
make music for, for living of life.
Theoretically, yes. But
obviously I haven't done that
yet. So what we'll do, I'm 28.
Oh, you're still okay now still. And
I got no tread on my tires. No, dude,
you're young. If you were 38, I would go,
Ooh. Yeah. Good luck. [inaudible] music.
You know what? I don't, I fancy
myself a nonjudgmental person,
but I fucking judge
people when they look me,
look at me and tell me that
they don't appreciate music.
And I met a surprising number of them
recently too. They don't appreciate it.
I know a lot of people who would say,
you get music playing, give me one.
I don't want to hear your songs.
You want me suck your Dick. Would
I Haley listened to your music?
That's the kind of hook or
Kevin gets to really whiny.
It doesn't like the house music.
I laugh Hugh grant's I poker that
I became famous for a little bit.
Yeah, got that blow job.
So what, like explain,
I've met people that will say they're
not into music and I don't get that
because to me it's a universal language.
Just as much math.
But I think even more so than math,
it's, it's inherent. You know,
there should be a love or a sense
or an understanding of rhythm.
There's something special about it.
There's something unique about it
that we're not really addressing.
It changes the way your
physical body feels. It makes
you more excited. You know,
it does things to you, inspires
you, it makes you feel good,
it brings you back to
moments of your childhood.
It's one of the most incredible works
of art forms of art that we have at a
great [inaudible]. So weird the
science behind some of it. Like with,
I wanted to know why house music,
it was something that persistent thump
got me up and made me want to move and it
seems to move some people and whatnot.
And it's like lower end frequencies
are triggered to primal portions of our
brain that we're sensitive to hearing,
uh,
approaching animals and elephant herds
and all that stuff. So it triggers that,
oh, I better wake up, be alert, got to
get going. And so that persistent thump,
what drives you and keeps you going.
There's so much craziness going on.
So tribal music, like literally
like fires up shit in your brain.
So you should wake up in the morning
bump, bump, bump, bump, bump, bump.
I play stampeding elephants when
I wake up. That's all I listen to.
You need to get on a podcast with
Eddie Bravo. We need to have you.
And him together cause he's got some
crazy theories about music and the,
Oh here's the 12 notes and
the 12 astrological signs.
There's isn't there a 13 astrological sign
and it's shifted people. They were like,
oh my horoscopes had been wrong. I'm like,
yeah, let me do that real quick on
that yet. But I like being a Leo.
I don't want to be a whatever.
I forget what I'm now.
If with the new method are you
really something different? Yeah,
it changed a lot of people. You were a
Leo before? Of course. You're a Leo too.
We're both Leah.
What is your date?
August 4th and your August
11th you're not a real Leo.
I like to think Miss Cleo cut you off.
I'm still Leo. They cut. I cut you off.
Let me say August 10th nope.
Your cutoffs on two September 16th you
were August 9th is that what you said?
August 4th August 4th it's over
bitch. I know. What do I know?
Like something gain and
her cancer. Oh, do you guys
subscribe to this perfect cancer?
Oh, I don't know. Not really.
I think Miss Cleo got a panel together
in her ivory tower and said, listen,
astrology kind of moves in the Google
searches. Let's create a new sign.
The crafty one though.
Oh,
I use C h. U s. How's that spot?
What do you say that, how do you pronounce
that? Oh, perfect. That's the new one.
That's November 29th to
December 17th. So if you, uh,
you have that crafty new Zodiac sign,
I dunno,
you know how the moon affects,
uh, like the ocean, right?
Like you know, the different tides,
the tides and everything like that.
Have you ever thought that maybe the
moon changes us because we're like, what,
99% water?
[inaudible] fuck with us too.
We would have some own tied and shit
going on in her. Everything does.
But is that a yearly thing? Is
there the mute moon cycle? Yeah,
the moon cycles year. That's
what seasons is, right?
Real problem is it would
have to be a real radical,
drastic change for them to measure it.
Like it might just because it changes
the way you feel is statistically,
it might not show a significant
jump as far as like, you know,
like disease or heart attacks or,
or assaults or anything crazy.
Cause I don't think there's ever been
anything statistically connected to lunar
activity.
But when you hear something like lunatic,
you hear like the Nate expression,
Luna Tech,
and then it's connected to the full
moons and lunar lunar that is the moon.
I mean that is ancient. There's
something to it, there's something to it.
And it might be as simple as when the
moon is out, people start freaking,
because you could see at night, you can
see at night. That's how it's a full moon.
Right. I can see who I'm mugging
is that, that's all that's good.
Singalong raised the assholes. Yeah,
I could. Yeah, it could be that easy.
It really could. I mean that's
a, that's a big difference.
Or you grow up in imagery of,
Oh, full moon and you here,
that's when the craziest come out with
a little towel and you go, all right,
now's my time.
Well,
that's one of the things I was rolling
soft shirts and go punch some ladies,
dear woman looking no explode,
this dear woman thing.
One of the things that Piss me off is the
women, they're not crosses, excuse me,
burning a women at the stake, which
is burning witches. The state,
they've connected that to Ergon.
They've connected that to a fungus that
grew on wheat because they had a late
frost and that it fucked up their
crops and the wheat was frozen.
And then when you have wheat that
uh, you know, like if you're like,
if food you like freeze food and then
thought out in the freezer, it again, you,
it's really dangerous. Yeah. Degree
and all this other shit and fungus.
And one of the, one of the
things that they've shown in, um,
in grain samples from that era,
from that time,
the Salem witch trials was that these,
these fucking people are high on Lsd.
I didn't even know it. They were
eating Ergo they were eating this,
this bread that has this fungus on it,
right.
And it has a massive psychological effect.
So,
of course they thought there
was rich craft the courses.
They thought they were there were
under spell. You know, there were,
there were so confused. They were highest
fuck on Lsd. Probably massive, crazy,
almost psychotic docents. Well, in
daily doses, on doses, upon doses
of that. I mean that's not like that.
That shit. I mean the half life is there,
but it will compound in your system.
And by the way,
there's modern versions of what the CIA
did in France where they dosed up an
entire town. They put it in their
bread and they monitor these people.
And do people die? They committed suicide.
They jumped off buildings. I mean,
people lost their fucking minds.
People never,
some people never came back and
they did this across the board.
They do this to children.
They did it to old people.
So we know that you can cause mass chaos
in hysteria by just dosing everybody up
with acid. And you know,
back then you didn't pass on
bread. There was no like, um,
you know, gluten bread because you know,
you might not get anything south.
Beaching I'm sorry, a purge.
I do hate you go crazy when you hear
people cleansing. I'm coming to cleanse.
It's not for me. I'm not shy. And
cayenne pepper and lemon juice.
That's all I got right now.
And I go to bootcamp and then hate myself,
but by a person throw up into it.
It's a cleansing.
Just everybody wants to fix
what they've already fucked up.
I did that shit for seven days
where he'd just drink lemon water,
charcoal and you can't eat anything.
It's charcoal.
Charcoal. The things you have to do,
you have to like before you do anything,
you have to buy all this
fucking shit from GNC.
And one of the things was charcoal,
milk thistle. I like all this bullshit.
I don't know why. I guess I was
show you didn't say you don't die.
And I think the charcoal,
maybe a absorbs shit.
Something that you do that for poison.
Poison. Yeah, that absorbs stuff.
I remember that for dogs.
When dogs eat something poison,
we're gonna make them eat a fucking
per cat. Whenever I'm at the grill,
I crack a little one and just pop
it just in case like five HTP.
You want to have any assistants
that are really good for you, Brian,
it's didn't seem good for you.
What happened to your,
what did you do with this cleanse?
It pretty much made you lose weight.
Did you lose weight? I want to fucking
throwing up your eating. Charcoals no, no,
you're just not eating
anything except live in water.
It was like 12 and we're making dinner.
What people don't understand is that
completely fucks with your metabolism,
but when you do something like that and
you lose weight where you're just not
eating anything, right, your metabolism
gets jacked and then when you eat things,
it's harder to bring them on.
Your body don't have as much energy.
You're going to have it anymore. So it
doors at all. It just locks it all up.
Super lethargic too. But the
beautiful thing about that diet is,
is that if you reintroduce food
into your system after 12 days,
you can find out our, Geez, a lot
more accurately than if say, you know,
you just try it. Don't be afraid
or rice or something like a you,
you first started by people do it.
It's not like I'm not doing it to find
out if you have an issue with people kind
of, it does reset your system. It
resets everything for you. So then you,
you're slowly introducing
food back into your diet.
I think you start off with rice and
you immediately could tell if anything
affects you with this rice. And then
you bring in like, you know, whatever.
And it's kind of cool for that way.
You analyze your diets and then you'd
apologize on behalf of all men on Youtube.
That's the next step.
I apologize.
And he immediately gave half of
all men fall. Selfish behavior.
Please take me into your bosoms.
It's just so ridiculous. What
about cons, buddy? What about cons?
Cause they're out there. Okay. And I hope
you'd get one and I hope she wrecks it.
She wrecks the whole thing.
Joe, we shouldn't give it
naturally and I worship you.
Oh wonderful. Magical woman.
Sounds like Superman's dad.
Another guy that came to kill superman
Zod doesn't really sound like that.
The unit brow guy.
Wonderful women who want to massage
your calves with Goat's milk and
yogurt. I want to massage
your buttocks, goats, yogurt.
So I want to weep on your vagina
of such a magical boobies. I didn't
want to fuck you tonight, sweetheart.
I just want to look at it. These guys are
at it and read. Read it. Russian poetry.
These guys, by the way, have a whole
bunch of other videos where, how did,
how to men find real feminism inside
them and Feminine Energy Inside Them?
It's like it's so, it's edit. Nami.
Just get to a Goddamn power
lifting gym son quickly.
I think that's what missing from their
life is crossfit. Creotine squats,
dead lifts,
someone's squash.
Someone needs to fucking tackle you
at some point in your life, okay?
If you don't know how easy it
is to get knocked off your feet,
you need to know that shit, bitch.
You need to work on your base. Okay?
I need to work on your sprawl.
Get your shit together. All
right? That was fucking,
you do a making youtube videos
were broken. Bitches. Stop it dude.
God Damn, stop it. I've got no ground
techniques is what you need to play.
The frisbee kettle bells. I got
them. I'm going to make a video.
I'm gonna show you guys how
not to be little queens.
I'm serious apology video on behalf
of those notes. That's a good idea.
We're going to do that. We're going to
do that after we're done here today,
Reverend Carr and Jen's.
Yeah, we'll do that. That'll
be our next video blog. Yeah.
We've got to get a shout out by
the way, to Cory loss. Chuck,
who did these two videos of Bobby Lee
from what? One of the past episodes I,
it's on Joe Rogan's website.
Joe rogan.net.
He fucking took like this audio of Bobby
telling these two stories and it's,
by the way,
it's podcasts 76 and fucking hilarious.
He did a really good job on
two brilliant stuff in the,
I forgot how funny those stories were
and one of them is Bobby getting in
trouble. The very first day this girl
showed up at work, you farted in her face.
She's sitting there reading or Sco eating
a yogurt and he walks up and sticks
his ass on her nose and farts
right on her face and she's crying.
And One guy attacks him
and she wants to go.
She was going to sue him and he had to
buy her a gift certificate for Burke
Williams to get massages and shit.
I love by the sinus obviously is awesome
and it's a story is just brilliant.
It's so God damn funny and this guy
put it to animation. It's so good, man.
He did an awesome job. So Cory, thank
you very much man. Check this out.
Thank you very much dude.
Those are awesome.
And anybody else who wants to do one of
those two? We fucking get on that shit.
I know there's a lot of really talented
people out there and that's what Carina,
I met Brian off the Internet. Yeah,
Brian and I met him. Yeah, craigslist.
I'm trying to stick with it.
My religion we get in the family.
I can't believe j date even exists like,
like what Jewish girl guide is going to
pay for that. Oh No, they will man. They,
they only want Jews. I have friends
that are Jews at only want juice.
Anything other than a
Jew. They, they learned,
I mean whatever the programming
that they got when they were young,
let's shit worked and they only want Jews.
There's also like a gay gangster dating
website that's hot, provide alcohol. I've,
you'd have to Google it.
He needed to go,
I'm going to pretend like I don't
have that one off the top of my head,
but there is a site just for
that, which is great. Yeah.
He used to work at gateway computers and
the day that Joe like called me up as
like,
hey,
you want to move to California and did
videos for a living and all this shit.
I was like, okay. And so I go
to my boss and I'm like, hey,
giving them a two week notice. He goes,
actually I need to talk to gateways,
closing all their stores.
And I'm like, oh. He's like,
you're going to have a two months
severance pay. I'm like, so yeah.
He was putting up these funny videos on
my message board and this is fuck man.
It was like, was it 2003 youtube? I was
just really good at canal compression.
That's all it took back in the day,
man. I made shit videos on the Internet,
but I knew how to,
I had access to servers from my
Internet provider that I started,
so we just dreamed all sorts
of Shit on real player.
Brian comes off very strange on the,
on the podcast sometimes and
some people complain about him,
but that's the reason for that is
he's just very weirdly creative.
He's a very odd guy and these
videos were fucking hilarious.
We have to put them somewhere.
Some of them up somewhere,
like all the one that you did, were
you, there was a, there was a guy who,
this was after he already moved here who
was giving him a hard time because this
guy was kind of jealous that
he got this job working for me.
So Brian made this video goofing on
him that uh, yeah, it was like, yeah,
he had a bay.
He just recently had a baby who was
married to this girl that looked like from
the girl from Harry art
looked like Harry Potter.
And so I just made this pretty much
this like what? Two minute video?
A minute and a half video that that just
was like, oh, you want to fight here?
Here's a,
I was good at flash animation at the
time because when flash first came out,
when it was like shock wave instead
of a shockwave is what it was called a
Macromedia shocker radio. Yeah. Yeah.
They, they loved my videos. I did.
So the some person from Adobe used to
send me flash flash 1.0 2.0 like this
really expensive software. No one had
access to this cause it was too expensive.
So I used to learn that
shit back in the day.
So I don't make all these flash
videos now. I can't even touch flash.
It's so fucking impossible.
Since Adobe vote,
I just want to gay demon.com is that the,
Whoa,
this is,
I'm looking for, you're gay. You're
telling me about your gay dating site.
So I go to gay demon.
It's so ridiculous.
It's so preposterous and ridiculous.
Have you seen Choa sneaky.
Let's say scribe to these people.
What we're looking at. Okay,
this is cause this is,
most people are going to hear this on
audio and they're going to be on there in
their car on their way to the gym or
you know, on the fucking treadmill.
I tell her, imagine that picture gay
demon.com does the angel and the devil,
the classic Angel and the Devil,
like from animal house,
one on each shoulder while the angel is
on one side and he's this buff gay guy
and he's got a guy sucking his dick and
then below him there's a guy stuck in
that guy's Dick and eating that guy's ass.
And they're the same guys doing both.
No, no, no other guys. And they're like,
this is a stack of guys like one of
those cheerleader pyramids and it's all
dudes, human centipede sucking guys and
fucking guys in the ass on both sides.
So the devil's getting his dick sucked
and the angels getting his Dick Sucked
and they're like looking at
each other like, Hey, what's up?
We're going to arctic SAR by. Look,
it was healthy. It wasn't so bad.
It sooner. The fire having a
[inaudible] seems to be no difference.
They both dragons, Google dragons,
fucking cars. That's a great Wednesday.
I'll fucking cards all like
anime of giant dragons.
Fucking cars in the tail height.
That's awesome. Gas tanks.
I hung out with the Asian
from a human centipede.
He had a party and I was invited to this.
It was the craziest thing ever.
You go to his house,
he had to like all these like statues of
the human centipede all over his house.
It was creepy.
I wanted it to film the whole thing.
But when you went to the guy
who created the no, no, no,
the Japanese or the Asian guy that
had sent a pita from Insinda peed.
So he has us all over his house.
So he's proud. He had a partner,
he had a party at his house.
He just happened to have all these cool
statues all out through his house of the
human centipede. Know there were
promotion promotional or whatever.
Plaster molds of himself
and a couple buddies. Yeah.
But interesting enough and I was trying
to dig and I think he's in the sequel
somehow.
So
I want to hear something funny.
There's something someone wrote on our
are on Twitter about this conversation.
He wrote consumerism with all these
exclamation points. It's ugly.
Talk about deeper shit. You horse.
Oh, that's what you know. Listen,
you dumb. Fuck. Okay.
When we're talking about fantastic
technology and the creation,
like human innovation,
the creation of a an m three or a,
an apple laptop or anything,
we're talking about spectacular new
things that are in our world right now.
It's not just about consumerism and
getting wrapped up in this whole, hey,
I'm not into money,
man.
I'm not in the consumer is a man.
Like, just shut the fuck up. Okay,
how did he send that tweet?
How does your phone,
what does your computer's
stupid live in a house,
dump content by a fucking smoke
signals for, he's a piece of shit.
I just want to address this whole retarded
mentality to criticize other people's
interests,
especially other people's interests when
it comes to things that you can attain.
So all of a sudden these things that
you can attain become evil things or bad
things or negative things.
We all have fucking transportation,
whether it's helped bus or whether
you drive your own fucking car.
We all have transportation. Okay. No one,
unless you are living in a solar powered
house and you write a fucking horse
everywhere. Okay. Everyone's
contributing. Noni,
that's listening to this
broadcast right now. Exactly.
Doesn't have access to something.
You've got its carbon footprint a
mother fucker. All right, and this,
this idea that somehow or another like
looking into this technology and objects
and things,
it's not being obsessed with create or
acquiring diamonds and walking around and
covered in jewels. That's not
what we're doing. What we're,
what we're doing is looking at the
incredible shit that human beings are
creating and how nuts this
is and how different this
is and just a few years ago,
that's it. All right. You stupid
fucks. Just [inaudible]. It makes me,
it's not trolled man.
It's a,
it's a mentality that comes up over and
over and over again and it's mostly a
justification of failure.
It's a justification of either the
lack of ambition or their lack of
participating in some sort
of, uh, you know, um, uh,
materialism, quest, you know,
they know they're not in the game at all.
So they criticized the game. You know,
I left. Fuck. It's like when I
see there's a guy in the Hamptons,
it's got some hundred and $80 million
house. It's the most expensive house ever,
and it's gigantic. You know,
when I say I don't say full dog,
good fucking capitalist, I go, wow, that's
incredible. Like that guy went for it,
you know? That's what I think. I
mean, it's not, here's the thing,
maybe that guy doesn't subscribe
to the game. Maybe he is capable,
but he's on Twitter or criticizing
you. So now and again, and let's see,
you said the carrier pigeon to
deliver that fucking message.
He's playing the game somehow.
Exactly.
Just not be for you to use in a fucking
computer. You know, look, we're,
we're all a part of this weird thing
called capitalism or this weird thing,
which capitalism is just
sort of an operating system
that runs society. I mean,
that's really what it is.
Yeah.
And I make like apple better and
you might like windows better.
They're all operating systems in
the same damn icon. I don't know.
I don't believe that,
you know,
capitalism is perfect by any
stretch of the imagination.
Nor do I believe is communism works.
I think socialism is a ridiculous idea
because it goes completely against human
nature. And when you start, you know,
criticizing people for things that
they've acquired, you're dumb. All right.
There's things out there that are amazing.
A big screen television is amazing.
Brian's got three d TV in his
bedroom. That shit's amazing. Oh,
that was a miss purchase.
No, no, no, no, no. Here's
what my, roll my sleeves up.
Step back. Here's my conversation. I
went to best buy to get a TV. Yeah.
I found the TV I wanted. Yeah.
It also had three D hot. No, no.
Just a normal TV and I was going to get
it. Then I, uh, checked on my Amazon.
I'm like,
how much does this TV?
And they didn't like the TV on
there was like pretty much the same.
But then they were like, they had the
three d version for $100 more. I'm like,
fuck that. I'm going to get the three
d version for a hundred dollars mark.
So I ordered it on Amazon, got
the TV right. Then you won't ever.
Then you get to spend an extra hundred
and $50 per pair of goggles and then you
get to spend an extra hundred bucks a
month or whatever for the specialist that
can deliver that. Amazon had this, uh,
how to deal if you bought it was for
Christmas or something like that.
If you bought their TV,
you get free 3-d everything and
you've got the three d glasses,
you got two pairs,
you've got some and you lose your three
d friends cause no one fucking cares.
Oh I'm sorry Bob.
I didn't charge.
Or Oakley's a migraine you have to charge.
Well I would not recommend a
three d TVs what I'm saying,
but if it's $100 more or something small,
then yes. Because here's the cool thing.
It's not, people don't know. It makes
everything three d if you want it to,
but it doesn't do it well. It doesn't
do it well on everything I watch.
I got to tell you dude, we were
at the, I've never seen one.
I haven't seen his but I have seen one
in person at the mall or a best buy we
went to see and they had
monsters and aliens playing.
I think it might be worth
it just to watch that movie.
[inaudible] it's the only movie. Like
when HD first came out people were like,
dude you got to get HD.
Why you could watch flamingos fuck and
the sunrise and high def and that's all
there was for it.
Which I get,
you know your eyes widen cause you like
watching flamingos fuck but after three
months that's all there was.
You play call of duty and three d I
have played three games. Yeah it's cool.
The onscreen display is a little
further out in front of your face.
You still colored glasses. You still
got a fucking headache. Still a sham.
I play call of duty for some
people it does for me at first,
the first 10 minutes you have and you
rewire your brain to go cross eyed when
I'm getting a headache and
now you're totally good.
I think it's more crazy as this new
Nintendo three ds where I'm watching kids
holding up their three ds right to
their face with this three d shit.
And they've already admitted it in Japan
that or doctor drew admitted that that
could cause your eyes to bleed and like
people are already getting fucked up
from it. And you know how kids
are with their fucking game boys,
they're going to put it in
there for hours on end smash.
Who knows what this is going to
do that they're fucking eyes, man.
You're going to get Bluetooth or some
fucking shit at the airport dude. But no,
no, I don't recommend three d tee
ball blended reality though. That's,
that's the shit you'll be able
to in the very near future.
You know Google goggles. Have you heard
of Google goggles? Yeah. No. Amazing.
So you point it Google goggles
at a restaurant or a landmark.
And it analyzes what you're looking at
and it spits you out a search result
based off that.
So you pointed at the Golden Gate
Bridge boom in the history of that.
So extrapolate from that.
It's crazy right now for augmented
reality in the translation.
This can take a photo of a building and
tells you what the building is. Oh yeah.
You could create a message board
off of just that photo. It could,
it could translate texts in real time.
You can have a check in,
you could have a menu pop out of a coaster
that's going to make contact lens at
one point. Well that's,
yeah, but so, so that,
that is step one.
So step two is they have these augmented
reality markers that you can throw down
and look at with a Webcam or
with a cell phone application.
And it'll make like on the three Ds,
it makes like a dragon appear and you
can walk around and look at it in three d
and Sharon Rose at it.
That's cool.
Now the next phase of that is doing
that without markers. So imagine this,
and I know some people that are working
on this right now and I'm trying to get
in the space.
You launch the APP on your cell phone.
You look around and analyzes
in real time in the cloud.
It looks at this table and goes,
all right,
there's a coconut water nutritional info.
Do you want to purchase by now?
There's a wine bottle. Oh, I know what
vintage that is from the fucking thing.
You can look at the microphone and tap
it. There's information on it. Wow.
Everything that the, the barrier between
Internet and real life is visual,
legally dissipated.
That's the next step.
But it's all going to have
real time tracking too.
So imagine hiking up to a
point at a mountain looking
over a city and tapping it
and having information on that city.
Come out having a communal game pop
out of it. All that shit's happening.
It's incredible. That's
going to be awesome. And it's
happening now, so fuck you.
Anti consumerism. Twitter,
Dick. Yeah. Fuck that guy to
apologize. Women on Youtube
urban either we're gonna talk
about mushrooms. I'm sorry. Yeah.
I thought that was just a mushroom
trip tonight. Well, we could, we could.
I got a date tonight. You got going on
with the misses. Where are you guys going?
Red lobster, Cheddar bay
biscuits. It's only Friday night.
I'm going to go red lobster.
Where does,
where do you go on a Friday night
with a message? Go out to eat.
Check out a movie. I heard
that then movie. I'm source
code's good Bernard source.
Go get your highness is great
screening.
What the fuck? Really? No kidding.
I was like, well I mean I like,
I do like Russell brand.
Why he entertains me.
You have to be in the mood for his
quote unquote brand of entertainment,
but same character. I liked
it so I watched him do
stand up. Oh wash, no sound,
but I was like,
whoa.
I like him whenever he's a guest on talk
shows like I'd love to interview him.
He seems, he seems pretty
interesting. He's a fascinating guy.
Who was your favorite person to interview?
Like,
who's the one person that you
think about all the time that like,
I can't believe in a shower in the
shower. Do, do. Uh, I like James Cameron,
James Cameron. I had a
last chance, James Cameron,
you know a lot of people accuse
him of being an arrogant,
but you know what I think did
in order to get that much done,
as much as he said we gotta be ahead
of being obsessed worker. What he did,
I mean,
look at what he's done,
but he was doing now it was advertised
was filling in all under water. Right.
He's doing the whole fucking,
and you didn't know that Avatar to
filming underwater with technology that he
created in order to fucking yeah, two or
titanic to film underwater and 20 bucks.
I got to hold the three d camera that
they used on Avatar and I held it for
about three minutes and wanted to
give out like my shoulder. It's like,
it's crazy heavy and I'm like,
you held this thing James,
like you're rich and powerful enough to
hire 40 people to hold the camera for
you is like, nope. Held
it on every single shot,
rammed down ramps and did all that
shit like he's, he's Gung Ho series,
but mother for all the shit that they
give James Cameron for being arrogant or
tough to work with or whatever. He came
on the show, had a smile, shook my hand,
was super nerdy about everything and we
even had them coming out with a folding
chair and smashing through a
brick wall and hitting it's,
he was super game to have a good time
and he cut his head on one of the foam
rocks that fell the second time you
came on the show with this big wall.
He burst through it like Koolaid, you
know like, Oh yeah, it picks up a chair.
He's going to hit a dummy with it
and I see like this little spot,
a crimson on his forehead and our shows
live. We've got a ten second delay.
So I'm sitting there interviewing
him and I'm just seeing,
thank God it's away from the camera,
but I'm watching blood slowly trickle
out of his 40 Jesus call I'm thinking
about is the publicist and the
studio and everybody else going like,
did you cut James Cameron?
I would have brought it up right away.
That would be glued. I hate to say
this, but I think we cut your head.
We cut you the fuck he's not
in pain. I'm so well look,
I'm so used trauma and
would get away with it.
What kind of a con,
if you were the type of guy that kills
people because a foam rock fell on your
head. Oh yeah, you would. You'd have
a fucking trail of bodies behind you.
Like Gingiss con that ass, you're
really, you're really, you're crazy.
It's not gonna. It's not gonna kill
you. You totally insecure about this.
You don't have to be more relaxed
about James Cameron told an awesome
opportunity there all that you caught him.
I still get him a great interview and I
had photoshops and me fucking the Navi.
So I was on, I really like, he was like,
the aliens have to seem
fuckable already said,
oh that was his big thing for Pandora.
He's like, I want you to picture aliens.
Someone you want to fuck.
And he talked about it and it's like,
I didn't want to fuck that girl. When
he got down with her, I was like, okay,
I could see it. I could see,
I could see her being attract.
Especially if like you're big and
blue to you're like, yeah, fuck it.
I'm going to make three
animals with their braid.
Why didn't you jack is Braden
to wear something like that.
You should work fine with your
hatch. Madison slash. Fiction.
That'll hit the net very soon.
Yeah, that James Cameron,
that guy's doing some crazy shit right
now and that was some amazing stuff.
Bummed.
I never got to interview Mitch Hedberg
Super bummed about that and the super
bummed it never got to interview Leslie
Nielsen Cause He's shaped, shaped my,
I just watched creep show the other day
and I forgot Leslie Nielsen was in an
Ted Danson, which was crazy.
But that, that Ted lesson,
Nielsen growing up was one of my faves.
I saw a naked gunky recently and it
was so weird seeing Oj Simpson a cause.
Your, forget how I, as a kid growing
up, I loved Oj Simpson. But it did,
especially from that role.
That was one of the weirdest moments in
human history when this, this loved man,
this guy who's like,
he played the game so well.
It was so charming and only
even dated white women.
So people didn't even
think of them as black.
It's like here's this trauma handsome
black man who spoke so well. Right.
And then all of a sudden he's gotten
people's fucking heads was allegedly some,
I'm going read the Chris. I was in like
sixth grade or seventh grade I think,
and I had the Chris Darden book on
that trailer. I was fascinated by it.
I was like, this is some crazy
shit that's gone. I got up early.
Me and my girlfriend, we were a,
I was living in North Hollywood,
my girlfriend bridge at the time.
We got up early and we sat in front of
the fucking TV and watched the verdict
and we both went, oh, were both like,
what is going on?
Like how is this real?
How am I watching this guy get off and
he's clap and art from, it was a racist.
That's why. Well in the glove didn't
fit. It was a little bit of both.
And it was also the weird thing where
black people wanted someone to win on.
There's wanting him to get it.
Yeah. They wanted him to win.
And I was the Rodney King
Rodney king thing fucked everybody out
when he wants to go and get beat fucking
half census with sticks without all these
youtube and cell phone videos of like,
my brother's a cop. By the way, you
should beat that guy. Have Sense?
They should just fucking shot him. Like
that guy was crazy. Messed up, asshole.
He was, he was high on PCP beating the
fuck out of cop. He was fighting them.
They had to hit them with sticks. Yeah,
they definitely got out of line. Yeah,
they definitely get a little crazy,
but,
but the notion that now you
can't fucking love cops truly do.
And my brother's one,
and he's one of the good ones and I
respect the shit out of what he does
everyday. I have sir, I read
teleprompter, I read words,
he puts a fucking shit in
a line and a lot of cops.
So with that stuff for cops,
that notion of not being able to film
them when they're performing their duties,
it's ridiculous.
And the fact that people are getting
their cell phones taken away and getting
arrested,
they're not even part of what's going on.
Getting arrested for invasion of privacy.
That's fucked. Yeah. There's law.
There's actually laws against videotaping
cops while they're doing their job,
but just ridiculous. Did you see that
guy in Seattle that punched that chick?
You ever see that?
There's a bunch of black women and he's
a little white guy and he's arresting
one and this,
this other black woman comes along and
she's like pulling the girl away and she
pulls him away.
She grabbed a hold of him and he turns
on blasts or right in the face and then
you know, all the people were filming
like, Oh shit, no he did and no, Hey Dan,
like wow, like this is like
this. What is this is chaos.
The story that the eight year old boy
that got pepper sprayed pepper spray it at
school and you're like, that's fucking
excessive force. Excessive force.
Tom's braid cop pepper sprayed him and
the mom is suing the cops in the school
district and everybody over
night, the headline of that,
you go, that's fucked up.
Who? Pepper sprays and boy it turns out
he like held up a pencil in the class,
threatened everybody said,
quote,
I'm going to kill all of you
mother fuckers that cops came up,
they were threatening to cops
and doing everything. I'm like,
you're fucking kid was out of hand.
If I said I'm gonna kill
all you motherfuckers at
a school and threatened to
stab people, I deserve a
little pepper sprays up. Yeah.
I mean it was eight years old though. He
was like eight or nine years old. Yeah.
You're like, Shit, the fuck I'm
coming to give me that pencil.
That's a trouble kid. You should arrest
his parents. That's what I'm saying. Yeah.
You got a kid that's that angry and then
the ones that kill everybody in class,
you need to find out what the fuck they
did to him. Yeah, absolutely. Sure.
That mom was a star on 16 and pregnant.
Oh,
that's just lately on TMZ.
It seems like every day there's a new
fight or a new person, but it seems like,
just like we were talking about with porn,
the porn is getting accelerating,
getting more and more fucked up.
Reality television is getting
more and more fucked up too,
to the point where how many people were
getting pregnant trying to be on that
show to be on the show. It
glorifies it. It says, well, I'm 16.
I live in the middle of nowhere
and I have nothing going for me.
I know what I'm doing and have a child
that will love me and an MTV is going to
give me a salary to put every
moment of this on the air.
It's so scary and sketch my moments and
put my life to a soundtrack that they
can sell on iTunes and I watch it.
We live in is try watching shit
on event show Macy's. Amazing.
Do you really watch Blake Bentley's great
man? My girlfriend makes me watch it.
Really? I totally do. Wow. Without,
without arguing. I watched, uh,
for the first time dancing with the stars.
What the Fuck's wrong with you?
You know, did you see Kirstie
Alley get dropped? No.
I heard about I should Google that and
I heard that the guy was trying to like
make excuses by my, my
knee gave out. It's normal.
It happens. Uh, Dan has
nothing to do with it.
When you're dragging a 400 pound woman
across the fucking floor has nothing to
do with the fact that she's a monster,
that she has eaten herself
in horrific proportions.
She's a monster.
She,
she took what was a hot shape
and for whatever. What is it?
Is it self loathing? Is it
indulgence? Is it gluttony?
She's just eating herself
into a road block.
You have to fucking work at getting
that big man a Shitty, yeah.
Especially a woman who's like
constantly talking about losing weight.
I mean her whole thing is like
losing that actress thing too.
So that was her whole shtick.
I loved,
there's a kid on youtube who was a
testing fruit gushers. Have you seen that?
He has like a snack review.
He's like 12 and he's already way too
big for his age and he does like a,
he reviews fin mitts gushers and eats
them and it looks into his Webcam and
tells you, yeah, that's a must buy
lunch. Again, I keep exploring.
You got to look at,
it's the fruit gushers must buy and is
this young kid on its Webcam and I'm like,
what are the four man? That's hilarious.
Where are the fucking parents?
Kirstie alley just never got over Diane,
I think. Is that what it is? Yeah.
Yeah man. Shit happens dude. It's a,
it's a problem when you're on a reality
or a big hit sitcom or you ever have a
weight issue being in front of camera,
like being on camera,
did it ever get to you and like you have
to look a certain way or feel a certain
way to be tall? I'm fatter now than
I've ever been in my life. For sure.
I could see my face and
I could see it in my gut.
I can wait be which I can
pinch a fat around me.
It's really because I'm traveling
a lot and it hurt my back.
Popped what's called a rivet
head or rib head is a, um,
it's what connects like it's
some shit in your back. Anyway,
point is when I did it,
I couldn't do Jujitsu for like two months
and I didn't lift heavy for two months
either.
All I did was just hit the bag and a,
I didn't even do that
all that consistently.
So I tried to let myself heal up and in
the process I ate just like I always do.
Isn't that the bitch of it? Like you, you,
you take your eyes off the prize
one second and it's gone. It's gone.
And muscle memory is bullshit. But
fortunately for me, no, it's not.
Looks totally real.
Not when you're in that two
weeks recovering from an
injury or something else.
Like that's, there's nothing
worse. Injuries are brutal,
but it's part of the game.
Held back is fucked up and I'm still
training through it like an asshole.
Really need to go get it looked at. What's
wrong with your back? Great question.
Yeah. When you say training,
like what are you doing? Uh,
started recently getting into
weightlifting. Yeah. Yeah.
Just heavy weight lifting.
I've never been in shape my entire
life. Yeah. I didn't want it.
It was that kettle bells.
Now just traditional teach
you the ways of Kettlebells,
son. But I uh, teach you the
ways of men. I did one of those,
those 23 and me test where you spit into
a vial and they analyze your DNA and
tell you what your predispositions
are. Right. You know,
and it was like Morbid obesity was
99.9% repeating and that was like a,
Oh, it's a genetic issue. Well,
I mean I'm predisposed to it.
Obviously we disposed off morbid obesity,
but look at your lean.
I'm kind of the only one in
my family that is though.
And I kind of developed it
neuroses about it at one point.
I've always worked out so much, I never
had to worry about my weight on TV.
But you know that that idea that
putting it puts 10 pounds on you,
that's complete total horse shit.
That's just fat girls who don't know
what they really look like and they see
themselves on camera.
Have you ever,
have you ever downsized standard def
stream stretched out on an HDTV? Yeah,
we'll put down, I will fuck
you up. W up real fast.
Like a heart video but in reverse,
remember those videos, heart,
remember this is the first time
they experiment. They were like,
how do we get this fat bitch
to look how we got a fucking,
we got to distort her frame and make it
look like we're looking at her through
like Alice in wonderland
seeing eyeglasses.
I saw a demo of software now for actually
you don't need tracking markers or any
green screen bullshit,
but you film an actor doing their
performance like you normally would and it
kind of does an Xbox connect
style analysis of their
frame and builds a skeleton
and it does pixel detection to
see where they're, you know,
I called it renaissance fair arms
where the turtle like hangs it,
sees what their rent,
rent,
bear arms ends right where the scenery
begins and you can real time dynamically
slide how fat, thin, tall,
or short a person is and it will render
the video after seem bulky or to make
them seem thinners. There's demos
of it on Youtube, right? 300 shit.
What they did with 300 I mean a lot of
people, they showed the 300 workout.
This is what they did to getting
such amazing shape. No, they didn't.
Do you know what kind of a fucking diet
you'd have to be on and how long you
would have to be on it and how consistent
you would have to be in the best shape
of your life.
It would take years and years of hard
training to reach like how Gerald wasn't
named Gerald Butler, Butler, Gerard
Butler, which if you see him now,
he did like SNL recently and
stuff like that. Dopey and soft.
It's totally show my girlfriend that.
I was like,
that's what that ends up
like a spartan looks like.
He actually got in shape for that,
moving on to shore and they added all
that other CGI shit to him to make them
look better than it really did, but shit,
she, that guy, I'm not into him, man.
I would about Spartacus loved him in
that movie. I haven't seen it yet.
I loved him in that movie and then
everything I've seen in him since then.
I'm like, God man, why are
you annoying me? You know,
how come I'm not always doing rom coms
now and Shit? Although he did do that.
What does that, what's Romcom
romantic comedies? Oh my God. You'll
knock out if you have not got a ruling.
But I've never even heard of that though.
Right.
I'm fucking industry.
That's why I know he's
never seen a Katherine Heigl
movie and rubbed her vagina
and a theater. Oh, miss an
owl. She's another one. Man.
I liked her in the first movie I saw her.
And what was that?
What was her big movie? The fucking
movie with Seth Rogen. Oh, she was,
oh, that was a, I liked her. Maybe I liked
her because she was fucking a fat guy.
I was like, oh, that's really sweet.
She fucked that guy. And then,
and then he never really got his shit
together and did read the baby books and
she's Kinda hot and cool.
And then at the end that one night stand
slash pregnancy totally worked out.
So Hey, knocked up. Beautiful. That's
how it works. You know that, um,
that other one that she did recently
with Josh Duhamel, that was his name is,
I don't, I'm not going to feel deeply
guy from Vegas. The guy from vague,
it's very nice guy. I did an
episode of Vegas. He's cool as fuck.
He's the one who's married to Fergie
from the black eyed peas. Okay. Anyway,
he did some movie with her and it
looks so, I didn't even watch it.
I just watched it on TV, on the movie,
on the screen of an, on a plane. Uh,
Washington a plane while I was writing
and I would look up and get angry or get
angry to help my writing on her
listening to fucking Hendrix.
I would look up at this stupid Shit and
all these slack jawed business faced
douchebags watching this
stupid ass fucking movie
when you know what's going to
happen. Like this is not a God
damn shocker in this movie.
It was no devil wears Prada.
I always accidentally watched the,
that the porn version of that movie.
I'm always with a girl and they're like,
oh my God, Devil's Wear Prada. And then
we turned on its devil's word, Nada,
and it's like come on like every day and
it's always the same. What, what chance
always watching that pilot
that I had an awe man.
I was so close to doing one of those.
I had an offer to be in one that was
like a born yet it was like soft core,
Cinemax, whatever. And I'm
going to play like Brad,
like the camera guy who gets to capitated
in an attic after getting blown.
And I so wanted to do it and just did
not pan out girl that I dated a long time
ago. I saw her once in one of
those. Oh so I was on another date.
I was at this chick's house.
I'm flipping through the channels and uh,
all of a sudden at a nowhere I could grow.
I did like a year before that was
on this fucking softcore porn movie.
It was like so cheesy and so
bad. It was so stupid. It was a,
but it was weird.
What was the setting?
Was it a tennis instructor was earlier
when you were talking were we're going
way back more than 10 years ago.
It was probably like 96 or something
to finish. I just moved to La,
so like, I didn't know it was
too, it was a much bigger,
much bigger shock to me because like,
just knowing someone and
seeing them on television,
like being around famous people
when you first moved to hog,
it's the weirdest thing. Like you
don't even expect them to be real.
You think they're like Holograms,
you know?
And then when you meet
someone in real life,
then all of a sudden they're
on television. You know?
It's like still fucking
weirds me out, man. It's, I'm
now, I'm getting used to it.
I'm pretty used to it now. But back
then it was really, and it wasn't,
it was a girl you dated and all sudden
you're seeing her in some fucking stupid
movie where she's making out
with some guy. She was, um,
a girl that was in a show
called the hardball with me. No,
that's it. I just saw a preview
for hard ball the other day.
It's not just confused. Two stories,
two stories. It does another one.
This is not the girl from hardball. It
was not a girl that I didn't, I'm like,
I didn't date that girl. I didn't
date that girl. It's a different girl.
But that was another girl that I also
saw around the same time also in a soft
car.
I'm still waiting to come across like
on a huge is or a red tube or something
like that. I'm waiting to come
across and fucking high school.
I know you have never had that happen.
I know me too playing the
numbers game and believe me,
I watch it enough to try to get through
that every day and I've still not found
it. Imagine if you didn't
notice and you were like Ha.
Cause like sometimes like
you know when if someone,
especially as time goes on like 10 years
ago, you forget, people forget people,
you forget,
you forget everything and then you're
beaten off and then like halfway in the
middle of the vase and you're
like, I fucked her. Oh my God.
Why did she let me do that to her
back then? I had a lab. Yeah. Yeah,
your asshole sore. No wonder
it's sore now. I know why.
I'm just happy that that when I used to
feel like there's been a couple times
where I fucked on camera before it was
back when like webcams first came out do
do do and I'm just happy that that
didn't that so it got on the Internet.
You fucked on the Internet.
What he's saying twice.
I thought that fucking what about that
thing man that can go back in time and
our time. Any a card that
imagine if it could go wow,
that's not outside the
realm of possibility.
I was drunk and I'm like I know agile.
Watch this.
You imagine if streaming was all recorded
somewhere because it's really just one
zero is going through a fucking computer.
If they figured out how to,
how to go back in time and like reprocess
your FBI white shades that are taking
all the copies of ones and Zeros that
are spitting through the Internet right
now. So right now the centers at at t and
t and little garden and all that shit,
they had machines that are mirroring
all that damn machines that are,
I bet this is true. This is not
conspiracy theory. Would you think?
Would you think? Absolutely.
You're documented proof.
Would you think like 15 years ago
they were doing that too though?
Like I not to that level,
but where do you think that there's
going to be technology to go back and
somehow you know, get that
somehow? That could be me.
I mean I don't,
I don't believe,
I believe from here on out whatever
here is not this year or not today,
but there has been up there. There was
a turning point from that point on.
All of those ones and Zeros exist
somewhere. They absolutely do. Yeah.
Well the really crazy idea is that at one
point in time there's going to be some
sort of a computer that's so fucking
powerful and that computing power and,
and what, what's capable,
what they're capable of,
of extrapolating from any
given circumstance. Is it?
Well they are going to be able to
do is see the world in every aspect,
like every,
every single thing about the world
today and literally put into a computer,
how did this get into place?
How did this get into place
in relationship with that
and go back in time and
literally be able to recreate the entire
model of life on this planet and life
in the universe.
Everything from the very beginning to
them until they get back to Jesus creating
it. Ah, which was only ironically a
few thousand years ago. It's that easy.
They don't have to go back very far.
Six grand. But here's the thing,
they've already figured out how to record
memories, right? They can, they can.
They can.
They believe they can put people's heads
and devices and record those electrical
impulses and see where they're going off
in the brains and then glean the ones
in zero data from that.
Right. So I did not know this.
How can you transfer it from you to man?
Well that's,
that's where they're still working on.
They don't, they know how to record it.
They can gather that data.
It's putting that data back into somebody.
That's the issue. So imagine in near
future where you put on a cap or you know,
you have your Johnny mnemonic
neural implant and you go,
I want to go skydiving today.
Doubleclick and you pay four 99 for that
adventure and it plays back somebody's
memory that was recorded of
them free falling. Maybe again,
I don't remember what the want Julia,
yes. Uh, that was all about that.
Whether you put in memories,
a strange, strange something.
Okay. Yeah. It's like a no, like, yeah, I
talked to him. I remember Johnny Mnemonic,
which was a great shot
of someone on Twitter.
I'm sure knows what the fuck this is.
Come on. You use the word, the whole,
the whole idea that movie
was that that's what you do.
You would like putting memories
in your head and stuff like that.
They can already record them.
Now the issue is playback.
So once they have that down, imagine an
APP store for experiences. Well, you know,
I thought about that the other day when
I was looking at my iPhone. Strange days,
knuckles, powerful. Um,
I was looking at my iPhone and it was
something that my daughter did that was
hilarious. And I was watching it. I
was like, okay, this is, this happened,
you know what happened five minutes ago.
Now I'm watching on this video.
It's so simple and so easy. Like this
is seriously like a time capture.
Like it's some, some, it's a very
remedial rudimentary form of time capture.
So imagine all the senses we have,
right?
All the stuff that we can perceive that
this thing just captures a two d image
of, right? So imagine infrared
with sonar, with feeling scent,
with feeling potentially, right? So
it's gonna you're gonna capture scenes,
but you're gonna capture every aspect
of a scene so that when you want to play
it back, it'll be just like
you're living in that moment.
It will happen to all those senses. You've
done the isolation tank. I have. Yeah.
You've done it at the same place,
the float lab and Venice and cause
we were talking about crash the mad
scientists down there that creates
these fucking things. But, um, you know,
he's working on that whole screen set
up, you know about all that, right? Yeah.
What do you think about all that now?
It's flat concept. I agree with it.
And in theory,
because for those who don't know,
the idea is that you're
floating in an isolation tank,
so you're isolated from lights sound,
you don't know where your skin ends and
where the warm body temperature water
begins. And because of that, your body
and your senses are zeroed out, right?
So you're,
you're completely open to everything.
And the idea is that there's gonna be
an LCD screen in front of you that's
projecting the perfect golf
swing or projecting how to
fuck like Rocco or how to
drive a race car. Like Andretti went,
what? Aco, dude, you went nine go thread.
It's classic. That's a classic.
It's not even dirty anymore,
but he's still a classic. He kept that
when you need it to. The point is,
his notion is that you'll be able to watch
that in a depth tank and because your
brain is so in tune and open to all these
memories, it's going to flood right in.
The problem is that that's not a
pure input method to the brain.
You're going to be aware in that moment
that you're watching an LCD screen,
there's going to be light
beaming into your eyes.
You will defeat the whole purpose of
sensory deprivation. Yes and no. Um,
but it also,
instead of just sensory deprivation and
minimize the sensory input and it allows
you to have more mental resources
to concentrate on the video.
That is true now that I'll give. So
if you want to watch a, you know,
a documentaries. Yeah. If
you want to watch those,
if you want to numb your senses and just
be focused into one thing, that's fine,
but I don't believe it's going to
somehow be programmed your brain.
That's how it was pitched
to me that it will,
that it will change your brain to do that.
It might make you more aware
of something that's true.
I think it allows my brain to use
more resources. I don't know Brian.
I mean I'm not necessarily willing to,
I mean look,
I'm a huge proponent of nothing of the
sensory deprivation tank in and of itself
being emptiness and nothing, nothing
there. I don't want any input at all.
I want to know hearing,
no seeing, no touching.
I want to like untethered my
body from my mind visually,
physically in every single way and that's,
you know, that's what I'm all about,
the isolation tank experience, but
I'm willing to listen. You know,
I'm willing to like,
it might be maybe,
maybe a little dry here so it just
doesn't sound, it doesn't, you know,
I'm not fully on board for that vision.
I'm done. I'd be game to try it.
I guess just to wrap that thing in
tin foil because there's still three g
signals and Wifi hitting your
body in there. You've got it.
I'm not down with this little screen
where I'm down with doing it in some sort
of a large circular thing where it's much,
much larger.
When I'm thinking of is
you're in the center,
almost like a in like a giant circular
pod and above you there's a screen sort
of like an imax screen and that is
the input and it's large and circular.
And when like say if you're, you know,
you have some sort of video on space,
it literally will become the whole sky,
you know,
that I think is possible and
that's a very fascinating time.
I'm waiting for someone to
create technology that beams
the image into your eye
because that's the only way you're
going to really be able to fully flood
someone's periphery, right. Is to
beam it in there. So imagine like,
so you don't see your own nose, you
don't see anything. Right? So imagine,
imagine a projector that's in that can,
they can quickly and dynamically
response to your eyes.
Maybe moving around are shifting,
but that's adjusting focal levels,
meaning in the J and image B into your
eye, giving you that shutter effect.
You'll be able to completely zone out
on something and your periphery would be
flooded [inaudible] on the
ground floor of that one. Yeah.
You don't want to be fucking blind.
That's why he's on the Nintendo three Ds.
You don't want the first one to
like see what happens in six months.
The first dudes who tried Wifi or
the first dudes who tried microwaves,
I was just trying to make it yourself.
Very stake. Now I have a vagina. Oh,
that's weird. Lasik, lasik surgery.
First guys to get in there and
get their eyeballs cut open.
I don't get it to me for that. That
doesn't always work. I mean it's,
they're pretty God damn good now and
now they do it and like it's a couple of
seconds and you get a video of it.
You get like a souvenir photo. Like,
like it's splash mountain. Here's where
we laser dry ball. We corrected the Lens.
I mean how many, how did they
figure that out man? Who,
how many people did they have to practice
on before they get that technique down?
So they use cadaver eyeball. How these
probably don't sigh balls and shit.
What's the, yeah. What's the closest
to human eyeballs and an animal?
I think pig is what if you could
transfer a pig eyes to people? Well,
they've already got now,
like again,
it hearkens back to
transhumanism where they can,
they can let blind people see rough shapes
and and hard edges with the light you
go five years from now,
they're going to have the same site
that we do to go 10 years from now.
They're going to have infrared
heat, vision, all that stuff.
It's a matter of time because
then it's just a lens.
As long as they can beam
it right in your brain.
That's when you contemplate
like where this is all headed.
When you look at this whole
transhumanism thing, you say,
well what happens if everybody
lives forever? What happens
if there is no death?
I mean, what happens and what
about the resources? Man,
we are already running already at Max.
You know we're already are. We though,
are we really at match? We're not really.
We kind of exaggerate that, right?
Well everyone, we say we're at Max
based off future projections. You know,
we're not at Max like tomorrow.
We're fucked.
We know at the current rate with babies
being born and ozone depleted and and
you know so much oil in the ground,
we know that in 15 2025
years we might be fuck.
So that's why we need to
invest in [inaudible].
I mean how much of our energy is projected
in use towards making food and how
much of it is towards,
you know,
fucking war and politics and nonsense and
how the ways we manufacture food right
now are making us sicker and there's,
there's a whole thing there but regarding
like trans humanism in 1520 years from
now, we're going to be alive for debates
that would be previously unheard of.
Should someone with a cybernetic implants
be allowed to run in the Olympics or
run for office or should your kid go to
the same elementary school when he's got
infrared vision and that helps him
with kickball like that. We don't know.
I have these conversations with
people when it comes to the UFC. When,
when they started talking to him,
how do you feel about banned substances?
Because so many people
keep getting posted.
Tiago Silva just got busted for turning
in non human urine because apparently he,
uh,
he's not a human or it took some something
for his back because he hurt his back,
but he looked fucking swole in his last
fight and it was super aggressive to
moles and one podcast dog.
There's 40 crazy new clothing
line that's going to be swole
in the abs on the outside of the Cock
Eagle. It's just from gay demon.com.
What I do is I just take the best gay
cock picture. That's what you need.
A rich deep v Neck with like a silhouette
giant caught coming out of the waste.
But like I've been thinking about,
I need that too.
And I'm so glad so many confirmed.
You're just gesture to it.
That's what the fuck was I saying
before we got on this? I don't know,
but I got into my bladder. I'll go
ahead. What were we just saying?
Uh, gay demons. Oh,
banned substances. Sorry, what?
Dragons fucking cars. Yeah.
It didn't pull up, man. Oh, here it
goes. One of the m banned substances.
Anyway. What I was saying is that
what people have to realize is,
look at this dragon fucking a Barracuda.
That's the first one I've tuned into.
That's pretty sweet.
Dragons.
Fucking cars.com look at that pink cock
or going into that muscle is so weird.
That is weird. That's really
fucking weird. Well, whoever
put those two together,
I don't know. People are
strange man, but this, um,
what I was saying about substances is,
what we're dealing with now
is fairly simple. We're,
we're dealing with people putting
chemicals in their bodies. We're,
we're dealing with people
like, dude, you take steroids.
Did you take growth hormone?
Did you take,
they can't even test for growth hormone
yet. They can test for testosterone.
They can test for a bunch of different
types of steroids that all work. I mean,
there's a reason why Barry bonds
got better as he got older. I mean,
there's a reason why Roger Clemens got
better, stayed good as he got older.
There's a reason why there's a lot of
these athletes that are well into their
forties that are competing and it's,
it's,
it's chemicals and what they're basically
doing is a form of a low level form of
genetic engineering. And what they're
supposed to tell you is that, well,
I mean it,
depending on what you're looking at,
whether you're looking at
old people who are doing it,
hormone replacement therapy,
a lot of people have different
takes on that and they say,
well that's okay because what they're
doing is just allowing their body to
operate as if a young body did and
allows them to continue to compete.
That way you get to see,
you know,
guys play baseball well into
their forties and do well,
but then you get guys who are like,
okay,
well this guy has taken EPO and he's
got twice as much red blood cells as the
average person and he has incredible
endurance because of that.
And then this guy is taking, you
know, Anna Var and he's, you know,
got a amazing muscle density and he's
a fucking animal. The, they're getting,
they're getting to superhuman levels and
it's there right now they're doing it
through, through, through chemicals and
they're injecting themselves with things.
But eventually it's going to be
much more complicated than that.
It's going to be genetic engineering
would eventually it's going to do is
they're going to be able to genetically
manipulate the code of a human being and
they're going to be able to create
human beings that are super humans.
So we have to figure out man what
w w w when it comes to, you know,
performance enhancing drugs and,
and trying to level the playing field.
So they saying, you know, as
far as like steroids in sports,
we have to realize is that this is just
the beginning. It's going to get way, way,
way more complex.
They're working on Myostatin inhibitors
where they've used these in mice and the
mice live longer and they jump fucking
three feet in the air and they look like
superman.
I mean this is going to happen and people
are going to start taking this stuff
and athletes are going to start taking
it because regular people are gonna start
taking it too because he like,
fuck,
I want to live three as long I wanna
be able to jump over buildings.
And if someone came along and they
have a pill and they say, Hey Brian,
would you like to take this
super athlete pill? There's no,
you actually live longer. You're
going to be healthier because of it.
There's no repercussions physically
and it's, you know, 100 bucks,
250 bucks and just changes you forever.
Well fuck you. Of course you take it.
We would kind of first, I let other
people take them at first at first,
but there would be a day
where we'd do the podcast.
Athletes are on the forefront of that and
trying to tweak and hack their bodies.
Yes. Slowly disseminate
down to the general public
where every day you're grade
schoolers taken a pill cause it's gonna
make them better at tetherball. Exactly.
And you're gonna be able to genetically
engineer your child from birth
eventually. Got to be able to say, I want
a six foot six you know, super athletic,
Super Mesomorph son with the
incredible Iq. Talk about class wars.
That is when it's really,
the shit is going to hit the fan.
When it's like talking about
the haves and haves nots,
you're kids have everything.
They're born with supervision,
Superspeed and super metabolism. That's
a very good, I keep up with that.
That's a very good point.
But people have to understand that the
inequality and then in the inequity of
the world is what fuels
innovation and when it,
what fuels people competing and
competition and it fuels like change.
It fuels growth and evolution
and in all forms of art,
in all forms of technology and all forms
of anything where people are comparing
their work to other people's
work and trying to compete.
It's important. I mean I,
I don't think it needs to be complete
and total inequality where you know,
some people are dying of starvation and
other people are eating diamonds there.
There's a balance to be achieved there,
but you have to realize that
in competition is growth
and that's how all this,
that's the motivation,
the energy behind all this.
I just imagined Kanye west starting a
new trend of, yeah, I mean pure diamonds.
I just mixing that my fucking smoothies
from Jamba juice that's done. Ah, fuck.
That's what I'm drinking. Yeah.
He wouldn't be far behind that.
Did you hear about this?
The kids that are dying off of uh,
taking bath salts and plant food? Yeah,
Ecstasy. It's called like diamond dust.
We've talked about that and it's,
it's sort of what they calling
it bath salts to sell it.
We were totally confused when we first
did it. We thought that bath salts,
it was actual bath salts and
someone figured out that you get,
but if they're just labeled it that way,
and apparently the chemical structure
of it is not technically illegal because
it's like a cousin of something that's
illegal. It's off. It's called Methadone,
I believe, but through put
meth in it. Even if it's a Ph,
don't put meth in the name of something.
If you want somebody who can really try
it and you were making them to get into
it,
they're making them illegal.
And one of the ways they're making
them illegal is there's a like a,
a law that allows you to make things
illegal that our next door neighbor's
cousin's to, to things
that are illegal. You know,
they use that with dimethyltryptamine
in five methoxy dimethyltryptamine you
know, five methoxy DMT and,
and dimethyltryptamine. It
was the big one that was,
they used in the 60s and that was the,
the army research lab used to fucking,
they had buckets of this
shit and scientists were
getting ahold of it and that's
how a mechanic got ahold of it and a
lot of other people got ahold of it.
Well when they lock that shit down in
1970 they didn't know about five methoxy
dimethyltryptamine, which is actually
more potent gram for gram than regular.
And you could buy it online, man, I
bought the shit from American chemical,
I ordered it online like really many,
many years ago as a powder or a powder
in the leg, a little vitamin bottle.
It's ridiculous.
There is enough and that saying to get
barbecue for the rest of your life,
you can cook your brain.
How do you,
how do you regulate and make something
illegal that your body naturally produces
and secretes? Well, you know
that's, that's a good point.
But your body also naturally
secretes testosterone.
And there's the question like we
should test roster and be available for
everyone could be like Sativex for weed.
They're like,
well you've heard of Sativex,
right?
What does that pharmaceutical form of
Sativa and they've done trials with it and
the UK and they find that, oh,
these medicinal marijuana. Yeah,
we can regulate it and
put it in pill form.
We'll call it Sativex and we'll get
the same effects as smoking a bowl,
a sativa weed. They've managed to
just isolate work. Yeah, it does.
It's synthetic THC,
but they're managed to make a
naturally produced product illegal.
And in sell you the pill form of it,
which is created in a lab. Right?
How long was four months?
Santo starts, you know,
genetically engineering marijuana
and making, you know, it's strains,
bacteria resistant this the,
and then throwing Johnny appleseeds out.
So everybody's going at so they could
sue you later. So yeah. How crazy.
Right there. They're patenting
nature. That's really bizarre. I mean,
they're trying to patent pig parts and
pigs and and human. Oregon's, I mean,
that's an Ext. It's, they'll
find a way to slightly tweak,
modify and impatent patent the
human genome. Sure. Exactly.
The own a certain level of person
and this type of person, you know,
they can call them like artificial
people or if you want a designer baby,
that's fine, but if he's going to
have blue eyes and be over six feet,
you all Monsanto a check every month,
that's going to happen.
That is going to happen. Right? You're
going to have to pay some sort of a,
some sort of a royal subscription fee
subscription fee for the perfect child.
Yeah. Apple's going to do it too.
Where is it all end? You know,
I mean there's the mechanical view.
There's a Kurt's we'll do you think so?
I hope not.
Do you,
are you familiar at all with any of
these people like the Graham Hancock's or
John Anthony West to the world, these
people that believe that there was, um, a,
a distant civilization
that was super advanced,
that somehow or another
everything fucked up.
Whether it was because of natural
disasters or whether it was because of
something manmade and that were
literally another generation like are we,
we have rebuilt from 6,000 plus years,
right?
Like they sent DNA or sent embryos or
whatever and shotgun blast them out of
space. Oh, I've heard that.
Yeah. That's another theory.
That's pants barrier. I mean,
well, no, you're, I think you're
talking about something definitely.
I'm talking about stuff
that came in on asteroids,
but what I'm talking about buy this,
buy this.
I'm John Anthony West and Robert Schoch
and all these other w what they're
subscribing to Graham Hancock is another
one is that civilization at one point
in time, whether it's
10,500, 12,000, 500 BC,
somewhere else was like very advanced
just like we are today. And Mayans,
they figured it out and then they somehow
fucked it up and we have survived out
of that. They're pretty sure that
the pyramids were built at 2,500 BC,
but there's also some other shows around
the pure about that's confusing though
because there's some stuff,
there's like certain styles of building
and then some of them they've found that
are like deep,
deep underground.
They've had like dig out and they were
covered in sand like the, you know, the,
the Sphinx,
when they initially found it was covered
in sand and even back in the like
hieroglyph days, this finks was covered in
sand. Like one of the, it was Tut, Moses,
the third, I think it was, had to uncover
it. Like that's part of the hieroglyphs.
I think what they're trying to say is
that at one point in time we had achieved
great heights.
Whether or not exactly parallel with
the way we live today with technology.
I mean it might've been
something different, right?
Might have been harnessing the power of
the sun with mirrors and limestone in a
way that created a new glass
as opposed to reaction.
Or it might have also been
a psychedelically based
society where we were,
you know,
much more into shamonic rituals and
communicating with the spirit world or
whatever the fuck that is.
It could have been a lot of that too,
but I think it's very possible.
It's very,
very ancestors could have been candy
flippers. Yes, yes. Well that's, well,
there's a lot of evidence to that. There's
a lot of evidence to believe the Soma,
you know, and you go to the, the vedic
texts and you know, they, I mean,
they all talk about
different psychedelic bruise.
It's pretty clear they're talking about
something that you take, you know,
and look, that stuff existed
forever. We know that.
We also know that ancient cultures have
been worshiping cows since the beginning
of time and not even eating them
even when they're fucking starving.
And that to me, reeks of some, some
deity me. Why is it a deity? Oh.
Because we use their milk and you know,
they,
they plow the fields where it's bullshit.
You're getting cow shit and there's
mushrooms that grow cow shed and your trip
and your fucking balls off.
That's what's really going on.
You're worshiping these cows.
The worship that they have is not
indicative of anything other than the
consumption of psychedelics.
It's like this weird love for this cow.
Like to me that's, that allows you to
unlock things and you for that to happen.
To me,
that seems people like naturally identify
with their own type and are as cruel
to animals as they need to be.
And when you're starving,
you need to be cruel to animals. But yet
they don't. And there's this like this,
this disconnect from their actual physical
needs and this is love that worships
on this, this, this, you
know, deifying this animal.
And we also know that there were
big on fucking psychedelics.
We know that their past has a lots of
references and the ancient texts to
psychedelics and psychedelic mushrooms
grow better on cow shit than anywhere in
the world. That's the best place for that
way. Where's that? Oh right. The island.
Really, you find them up there and
you're going to take the road to Hana.
And when you're there, like the hot
of mountain resort, big old hill,
you just climate at about six in the
morning. It's everywhere. We can go that,
you know, the entire Pacific
northwest of the United States,
the entire Pacific northwest
literally is like a mind of spores.
It's like one gigantic organism
life form like a base of spores.
They're fucking everywhere up there.
Psychedelic mushrooms,
like there's people that go up
there and find them and grow them,
but it's all connected with it.
I mean literally if you believe that that
psychedelic mushrooms are some sort of
a life form from somewhere else,
which a lot of people believe,
they believe that GE much like they
believe that. Um, you know, the,
the pants barrier theory that we were
talking about earlier that, you know,
amino acids and all sorts of water and
different things came from asteroids hit
earth and that started in seated life.
They believe that somehow or another,
these spores came from other planets.
You know,
cause spores can survive in a vacuum and
spores can survive the deep radiation
of space and right into
fact that this is like some,
some thing that permeates one entire
part of the country. You know,
I remember watching or reading something
about it, about, you know like if you,
if you like connected at all together
like you know, the, the, the,
the how far and how wide it is,
you know,
and these mushrooms growing in
the same space, in the same area.
That wouldn't be c words come out
of somebody's mouth once. Really,
that was the fucking trip of my life. What
do they look like? English words. Yeah,
I was,
it was,
it was at a moment and I could hear
conversations in the other room.
I couldn't hear them,
but I could literally see words and it's
like three d text form floating over
the partitions in this guy's loft in
downtown La. And I was like, what?
And I looked at them like, and I started
recalling to my friend who was there,
granted this is all, we're
all fucked up, but I'm like,
they're talking about such and such
in there. Well how do you hear that?
The music so loud, I can see it and
went in there and was literally,
as people were talking to me,
I was watching their mouths open
and the words that they were saying,
we're physically coming out as text.
Their mouths were warping around it.
And so I must have looked like a tweaker
and a half watching these words go by.
Cause I was trying to read it like
a ticker as they were talking.
So the outside world,
I was scratching and going like this.
They probably thought they'd fucked me up.
Did you ask them if you were right?
I was absolutely right.
We talk about it to this day,
like I saw words coming out of
people's mouths was reading.
Maybe I was hearing it and it was like
some you're, it was just cool. Yeah,
like a synesthesia and my brain was going,
this is what they're saying.
I don't know. But you checked with
them on what they were saying? Yeah.
What we want. Let's just
mushrooms. How much?
Not that much lightweight
to couple stands. Couple of
caps. Really peanut butter.
See,
see what's Weird Kevin,
is that a lot of people especially
that I've met through Joe there,
their firm believers of like you can just
got to eat a shitload of mushrooms and
about,
I've never done this my whole life.
It's always been like half an eighth
maybe. I just took it out of it.
It sounds like that.
Yeah.
I just took like a half of a half of
the eighth recently and had probably the
most hardcore visuals I've ever had in
my life growing mushrooms. I when I like,
I have friends that smoke Salvia and
they'll see like visual distortions in the
room. Like they'll look up in the
ceiling, will rip apart and they'll say,
there's like snow will come in. I'm
like, that's cool. That sounds fun.
When I smoke it, I go to another
fucking dimension to another dimension.
Do it right. The first time
I did it. Oh yeah. Yeah.
I only did it once and I didn't do it
right and I just did what they did.
I was like an out of body experience.
But you know when you guys
are talking about you,
you absolutely can get a brilliant and
beautiful experience from just a little
bit of mushrooms. There's no doubt
about it, but it's not the same.
How do you know that? How do you know
that? Because I've done them both.
Because you've done a little and
you've done a lot. Yeah, but you could,
if there's a, there's a point.
It's all about the mushrooms
leasing. How do you know that, dude,
this is like documented
throughout human history.
People have been doing it the shamonic
way where they take this large dose and
silent darkness and they do it and they
have a different experience than when
you take smaller and they
know what they're doing.
Know physiologically the different
effects that it has on the human body.
But I've had the most I've ever had
was probably maybe a quarter mushrooms
before. And what do you, are you
not listening to what you're saying?
Because if you're saying
the most I've ever had,
then you don't have experience about
taking five grams or six grams.
I know you don't have that extra,
but I'm saying in a different way.
I've had a quarter before and yes,
I've had a crazy ass showroom experience.
I had half of an eight the other day
and it blew that shit out of the water
times up million. Then it was just
different mushrooms. It was good.
It could be that.
It also could be where you are physically.
It could be what you had in your
stomach. It could be, you know,
there's a lot of different things,
but that's doesn't mean anything
because you haven't had the full blown
experience of the big dose to
compare it to even do anything.
When it gets to a certain point.
I was gonna say,
I don't know what's beyond that because
I would have pissed myself and has
silver, one of the best thing
go any further than that.
Physically Mckenna did a lecture wants
and he was talking about a friend of his
that chose to remain anonymous,
but he was like this like
crazy psychedelic guy who
every time he did mushrooms,
his goal was to try to tolerate more and
he would go to like 10 grams and have
these like the God knows you will.
What you do is you literally
completely dissolve.
You see sue exist and you make contact
with whatever the fuck it is that you're
making contact. It seems like at
first it seems like another life form.
It seems like some sort of a thing
that's communicating with you and then
somewhere along the line it
becomes like another world.
It becomes like this,
this goes away and you go into this next
sort of dimension that's incredible.
It's so religious and beautiful.
And, and when I say religious,
it's like iconic imagery and but almost
indescribable because they're morphing
and changing around you.
But it's all like love and
wisdom and warm as powerful.
It was what? It's not poisoned. The
LD 50 rate is ridiculously high.
You have to eat like shitloads of
mushrooms to die. It's not poison. Yes,
but probably not. I mean, mushrooms
is a mushroom. It's a, it's, it's a,
it is a poison to your body. No one's
not mushrooms, not poisoned. Brian.
It's like salt is poison.
It's salt poison. Well, if
you need to have kind of salt,
you fucking die. It's not, salt is not a
poison. Strychnine is a fucking poison.
What psychedelic drugs are,
is there something that allows your body
to tune into whatever the fuck it is to
change the, the, the chemical
composition of your brain to,
to fuck with your neurochemistry to the
point where some would define that as a
poison.
They would say you're poisoning your body,
but there's no negative health
react, but you don't, but it's not,
it doesn't wreck your bites.
Shocking.
Worn out mushrooms and silicide
been to depressive oppressiveness,
bipolarism manic manic states.
Now I'm not saying all,
but that's not exactly, it could have
easily, which is why they're doing,
which is like a hardcore drugs.
Salvia killed some kid,
but he was having issues and of
course, yeah. What I'm saying is,
you know I,
I'm absolutely with you that small doses
can give you beautiful experiences,
but it's a different thing
than the high dose is.
The high doses are ego obliterating. I'll
never achieve that. You know, you scared.
Oh yeah. [inaudible] homie
from that last time, man,
I know I had a flight the next day and
I ended up at lax swiping my credit card
from terminal to terminal in the machines.
Hoping one would recognize my itinerary
and spit it out. It was like, oh,
this was really unprofessional.
I probably shouldn't eat.
And all those mushrooms the night
before a flight to New York and a shoot.
But you figured out how to get there.
How could you not figure out how to look
at your phone and your email that tells
you what the one of those things.
Good Shit.
I had a really strong DMT trip,
which is the last one that I had and
I haven't done anything like that in a
couple of years because it was,
it was so powerful that for
like a couple weeks afterwards,
nothing seemed normal. I mean, everything
worked. I could read, I could watch TV,
I could have conversations,
I could talk to people.
No one would know that behind the surface.
I was like,
I don't believe in the world anymore.
I don't trust in this dimension.
You're waiting for Morpheus to load a
patch to fly a helicopter and your brain
to believe you. Now you're
in the matrix. It was so,
it was so humbling and so crazy
and moving and people go, oh,
it's just fucking drugs, man.
Just doing drugs and you get you.
Your head's getting all fucked up. It's
all you're doing is you're doing drugs.
Yeah, maybe. Maybe, maybe
not, but you don't know.
We're not really sure what's going on,
but I guarantee you that changed my life.
Right? I can guarantee you that whatever
that is, if it's just drugs, you know,
that just,
just drugs changed me as a human being
and made me reevaluate everything you
know and is still to this day like Honda.
I think it's, well, it's just religion.
That's just something you believe in.
That changes every facet of your life
that has given you visions and made you
appreciate things in a new way.
That's all it is, is just the deal.
It's the real religion. The real religion
is a psychedelic experience. I mean,
there's a John Marco Allegro book
or prescribed to him, but his, uh,
John Marco leg rope book,
who is the,
one of the scholars that
reviewed the Dead Sea Scrolls,
he decipher the Dead Sea
Scrolls for 14 years,
worked on it and at the end of 14
years he said that the entire Christian
religion was a huge misunderstanding.
And what it really was about was the
consumption of psychedelic mushrooms and
fertility cults. And he
wraps, wraps it all up.
It's almost impossible to follow, you
know, like to follow the, you know,
the origins of the words and it's like,
it's really trippy shit.
But the fact that this guy has got
it locked down to this one mushroom,
this psychedelic mushroom has taken
throughout Europe, you know, constantly.
You know,
we know that the vikings took mushrooms
and they would go on Berserkers,
you know, they would call it, they would,
they would get fucked up on mushrooms
and then go attack villages. You know,
I mean, that's how they
wrote. Yeah, man, they would,
they would get high on mushrooms.
I still maintain,
I found my spirituality on
Salvia. Yeah. I'd smoked,
start with small doses and then I've done
about six times and I don't want to do
it again because the last time I did
it was so fucking powerful and magical.
It's similar to your DMT experience,
but I tell me a super potent
flew out of my brain, you know,
and just went kind of Canda tonic and uh,
I saw parallel universes,
parallel dimensions spiraling
out of the corner of my eye.
Like I was just sort of floating in this,
in this abyss.
And I saw it and was rotating. It was
making a noise. It had gravity to it.
And it was almost like I
could see wedges of reality.
If I couldn't look directly at it, it
would blind me. But out of my peripheral,
I can see these wedges
of reality going by. And I was like, what
is that? What is that? And something said,
just fucking go for it. And so I,
I remember reaching out my hand,
what it felt like my hand at the time,
and it's slowed this fear down and,
and it sucked me into one of
those wedges and I was feeling,
I felt like I was a kid running around
and what felt like a Russian stadium for
whatever reason,
holding a flag and there was confetti.
And as with a bunch of other kids, it
was a halftime celebration or some shit.
And I was like, Yay. Oh, we, it felt
it as real as any other experience.
I've had my life and a shotgun out of
it and that it was rotating it and went,
oh,
what can I do that again?
And I reached down and slowed it down and
I went in and then I was driving a car.
It was like another reality that I could
have been living and it was just all
dimensions and you can't tell me, you
can tell me. It was drugs, drugs, drugs.
Cause it totally was to some extent,
but you can't tell me it wasn't as real
as any other experience that I had.
And when I came to on the
couch I just went, Holy Shit,
you're fucking freaking me out man.
Did you record all these Salvia
user? Uh, well, yes. Yes I did.
Actually.
I have my buddy who was writing it down.
I had one,
uh,
in the tank where a eaten some pot
and when you eat a lot of pause,
especially if you eat the really strong
shit and you can have some incredible
visuals,
man,
have you ever eaten in on a plane then
close your eyes and see like cartoons and
like Lou drive the palm springs not too
long ago on some edibles I had a very
similar vision.
Whatever it is,
hallucination is what you parallel
dimensions and you what? Mine with mine,
they were,
I was in the center of what it started
out with me would it started out with is
like I would the tank, I mean how
many times you done the tank? Uh,
only like three or four. When with,
I've never done at high. She was like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
Son
met some dude named crash on the
boardwalk who was trying to tell me about
vibrating my spirit and, and
he's like, yeah, hop in my tank.
Yeah, he's crazy. But he's right.
He's right about a lot of shit,
but don't begrudge me smoking pot
before I hop into crashes. Time machine
played too many point and click adventure
games to know that that could happen.
It started out, it started
out just getting to the
center, relaxing, letting go,
and then once I let go,
then it always feels like once I get
to a certain point of relaxation and I
completely calmed my mind,
then it starts to take me away.
Almost like as if I feel
like I'm in a river,
I feel like I'm a wash and of visible.
Well as I was doing this I,
I came to a point where I recognized my
space and then the space of the planet
and then the planet in this space of the
galaxy and the galaxy and the space of
the universe.
And then the whole universe became like,
there's a bubble that was trapped inside,
some gigantic infinite like ball of yarn.
And each thread of this ball of yarn
was like one universe after another
universe.
And they were all together swirling
in this moving ball of yarn,
of universes,
connected like circles,
connected even with a tube like the
connected them all together and it was all
luminescent and it was all,
I was trying to take in all the
information that was going on,
all of these different various worlds,
but it was all different and all the same.
And
it was all happening simultaneously.
And as I was trying to figure out like
how big this is, this ball of yarn is,
it got literally too big for me to wrap
my head around and I had snapped out of
it, right? And then I lost it in the tank.
A couple of hours. Several hours. Yeah.
The deeper I get is that the longer
I'm in there, the more I can relax.
And it's almost like you achieve
like different wave lengths,
different mine frequencies,
you know, like you know,
I mean I know that you do in
meditation and extreme meditation,
like they've taken monks and they've done
studies and so jealous and envious of
that shit of monks.
Well just the people that
can deep meditate and get
to that place versus needing
to take Salvia or needing to some DMT.
I got this,
I'm not capable of shutting it all off.
Like deep meditation.
Like yeah,
if I did it every day and that was my
only existence that sure that it's fine,
but I've got a mortgage. Yeah Dude, we
gotta I gotta cheat to get to space.
You don't want to get laid and you
want to watch TV. Fuck all that monk.
She Netflix and cartoons. I'll, I'll
find the universe by smoking it.
You can get it there though.
You can look like a conversation with
my ego on Salvia and that was trip.
I felt it inside the visualizer
and my Xbox three 60 of all places.
That son of a bitch, I'll put
that on it. And what at the time
you use the vision cam so when you move
around it would make the visuals on the
screen go nuts. Jeff Mintzer is a
genius. He wrote the three g o get.
Do you remember the three dio at all?
You said about the freedom of the console.
Yeah.
He used to come with a trippy game where
you could control this kaleidoscope and
when I used to be a kid do 11 that said,
that was like the first
level gets here you go. Well,
I took a rip and handed the ball
to a friend and was like, Oh shit.
And there it went and I
started dissolving. That's
similar like single molecule.
Oh and the thing of my couch now and
my couch has made of molecules. Cool.
Get out of that projected fourth
and was like, oh, the Xbox.
It's pretty sweet right now.
Why don't I just fly into that?
And I did and there was this pulsating
ball after I went through all these like
little wormholes and tunnel and it was
pulsating to the beat of the music that
was happening. And I knew that I could
go further, but I was like, what? What's,
what's going on here? And he's like,
oh, I'm every issue you have right now.
And you know exactly
when I was like, oh, what's, and my
x-box visualizer, what's going on Bro?
And he's like, you know, you know
what? You need to get an order.
You know you need to fucking fix your
shit. I was like, yeah, I know, I know.
He's like so relaxed and
fix it. It all, all right.
We had a convert whole
conversation and I was like, cool,
can I go swim around the visuals
now? He's like, party on Bro.
Like totally gave me the permission
to go flying around. And it,
that's one of the most amazing and
an underappreciated aspects of any
psychedelic experience is the work that
you do on your own personality and your
mind.
And,
and uncovering all the bullshit that's
fucking league match why people have,
not everybody, but that's what like
some of my friends have had bad trips.
It's obviously,
oh,
I reached a point where I felt like I
was going to die and I felt like no,
you were getting deconstructed as a human
being and you weren't ready to come to
grips with the fact that there
might be something bigger than you,
that there might be something real
that you are not to experience.
And you couldn't let that go. Yeah,
absolutely. Issue. Well, paranoia. I mean,
we had this conversation many times and
someone recently brought this up on, uh,
on the message board. They were talking
about the people that get paranoid,
that people that aren't
dealing with their life,
they've got some shit that they
don't like about themselves.
They feel fucking creepy.
And that's the reason why they freak
out every time they get high. Right?
It's like the marijuana,
it does not allow you have secrets.
The marijuana turn some
lights on the corner in the
attic of your house and goes,
Hey, what's going on? It's all
this shit over here. What do you,
what are you hiding over here?
Was it my kiddie porn or out
through your mouth and your eyes.
And then I had my internal
monologue switched with my
external monologue once on
uh, on, on, on mushrooms. And I
remember like looking at him like,
why the fuck are you looking at me
right now? Like, what are you doing?
Is that a red watch? Why the fuck are
you staring at me like that right now?
And I was saying it all out loud. It was
completely switched about 30 minutes.
People were chatting with my internal
monologue and it was everything I wanted
to externalize with swallet
inside. It was like, fuck I,
thankfully I'm a decent enough person to,
I didn't admit to the bodies in the
basement, but like I could have been bad.
Do you believe? Do you think
that psychedelics, are you,
have you ever even considered that
their agents of human evolution and that
they're here to rocket rocket
you forward and rocket us four.
And the reason why we're
not monkeys, I mean, I, I,
I believe in a mixture
of all those things,
but I certainly can understand an animal
taking something and thinking about a
rock in a different way and going, that
could be a spear to kill an animal. Right.
You know,
like why the fuck not if I can see other
planets and have a chat with my Xbox
visuals.
Why couldn't a gorilla and a forest
have realized a better way to keep warm?
Yeah. Psychedelic mushrooms have been
around the current state for thousands and
thousands and thousands of years long.
Predating what we know of
as human civilization. We
know monkeys weed, anything.
They'll try shit out, you know, they
try anything out. Don't pee in their,
on mounds and a tree. It's a greatest
video ever. It is pretty good.
They'll do whatever they want,
almost as good as the one where he
flashlights the frog, all that. Plus Frog.
I love it. She'll just, he goes,
he goes through like the gorilla suit tra
like he tries different positions with.
It's like, I'm gonna sit on
my back. That's not enough.
I'm going to tea bag them for a while.
Like he really puts that frog. It's crazy.
And it's amazing that people are sitting
there watching too and they're laughing
and fill me and joking around.
Families are there and shit and
this chimp is just fuck mouth.
Fucking the shit out of this.
Meanwhile Hydrawise from real sex and
you turn your eyes towards all the
slaughter and murder on TV.
You know,
we talked about this before but I'll
just bring it up one more time before we
get out of here.
There's a website that had this horrific
video of a drug killing in Mexico and
this guy had been chopped
up into all sorts of pieces.
They showed everything in graphic detail
except they cut his hands off and in
one of the hands was his dick and balls
and his dick and balls. They it out. It
got to pixelate that we can't let the
kids know what else. They're ridiculous.
Weird world.
Do you think,
I mean you hear about the protests
going on right now in Mexico.
Do you think that's about to boil over
really, really fast? What is going on?
What are the thousands of people in the
streets about the drug cartels and the
violence on the same day that they
discovered mass graves and they discovered
another massacre? Yeah. Yeah.
This is the same place where there's 72
people recently. This was over 50 people.
It's terrifying, man. That's
really close to all of us.
It's all happening right now.
We got to go to Libya. Yeah,
we got to go to Afghanistan.
Keep that war on drugs popping along
so that we finance all that shit.
It's all fucking crazy,
Kevin. It's all crazy.
This has been the uplifting podcast
and a bad ass pockets, a podcast.
Anytime you want to come out and
you're more than welcome. Fascinating,
awesome conversation. Appreciate
it. I enjoyed it. Very,
very much pleasure to have
you on and thank you very
much for wanting to be on it
in the first place. Thank you. Thank you.
So you can get ahold of Kevin on Twitter.
Please follow him for he is in fact the
shit and you can get him on his Twitter
is k p e r e I r a k
Perreira in the house.
Ladies and gentlemen, thank
you very much. Thank you.
So what's the attack of the show in
g four? Yes. When is an almond g?
Four 7:00 PM Eastern. And you can
find us online g four tv.com. And you,
you fill it Monday through Thursday,
correct? Yeah, we're live every day.
Live every day. You, you
dirty hose. All right.
Thank you very much for
checking on everybody. Um, uh,
there's still a couple
tickets left for Toronto,
April 29 for the Massey Hall theater.
A Philly is a,
I believe it's totally sold out even
though we added that second show on
Thursday. If it's not
second show, Thursdays,
all that's left and that is a next weekend
and that's a full desk squad pitches.
That's Ari Shaffir and Joe
Diaz next weekend in Philly.
And I'm excited to see you bitches.
Thank you very much for coming in and uh,
coming in. Okay, come on. The
fucking show's over. Check
out desk squad. Dot. TV.
Yeah. Checkout desk squad, Dr TV,
and subscribe to death squad if
you're looking for more podcasts.
Brian has his own podcast network
thing going on on, on Itunes,
and it's a, it's called death squad.
And every day it's different shows.
It's Ari Shaffir,
Tom Segura,
high level standup comedians are sitting
around shooting the shit and it's great
stuff. And uh, that's it. All right, I
love you freaks. Where's my flashlight?
Oh yeah. I'll get Kevin flashlight
and go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link that says flashlight.
Get 15% off the number one
adult toy in the world.
And Kevin's going to fuck
one tonight. Yes, yes. Thank
you everybody. Love you. Bye.